programming throwdown episode 131 supporting your favorite creators with brave with jimmy secretan take it away jason hey everybody um so you know as most of you know patrick and i are huge fans of brave um we love the browser i recently switched to the search engine which uh is working really well i'm a big fan of that um i love the sort of ethos around brave and i've uh been a big fan for a long time. I'm super excited that we have Jimmy Seckerton here, who's the VP of Ads and Premium Services, to talk about Brave. We're going to dive through really how it works, where it came from, the inspiration, and what they're doing next.
programming throwdown episode 131 supporting your favorite creators with brave with jimmy secretan take it away jason hey everybody um so you know as most of you know patrick and i are huge fans of brave um we love the browser i recently switched to the search engine which uh is working really well i'm a big fan of that um i love the sort of ethos around brave and i've uh been a big fan for a long time. I'm super excited that we have Jimmy Seckerton here, who's the VP of Ads and Premium Services, to talk about Brave. We're going to dive through really how it works, where it came from, the inspiration, and what they're doing next.|||programming throwdown episode 131 supporting your favorite creators with brave with jimmy secretan take it away jason hey everybody um so you know as most of you know patrick and i are huge fans of brave um we love the browser i recently switched to the search engine which uh is working really well i'm a big fan of that um i love the sort of ethos around brave and i've uh been a big fan for a long time. I'm super excited that we have Jimmy Seckerton here, who's the VP of Ads and Premium Services, to talk about Brave. We're going to dive through really how it works, where it came from, the inspiration, and what they're doing next.
Really excited to have you on the show, Jimmy. Well, thanks. It's great to be here. Yeah, really excited. So yeah, let me start by, I can tell the audience a little bit about Brave. Brave was started by Brendan Eich and Brian Bondy. And Brendan Eich, who a lot of you will know from Mozilla, the inventor of JavaScript. And they set out to create this private by design browser, most secure, most private experience on you know, on the web. I joined, I joined actually a little over three years ago, you know, and one of the things, you know, one of the things that's really interesting about Brave, and if you haven't tried it out, please go to brave.com, you know, you can download it for a desktop,
Really excited to have you on the show, Jimmy. Well, thanks. It's great to be here. Yeah, really excited. So yeah, let me start by, I can tell the audience a little bit about Brave. Brave was started by Brendan Eich and Brian Bondy. And Brendan Eich, who a lot of you will know from Mozilla, the inventor of JavaScript. And they set out to create this private by design browser, most secure, most private experience on you know, on the web. I joined, I joined actually a little over three years ago, you know, and one of the things, you know, one of the things that's really interesting about Brave, and if you haven't tried it out, please go to brave.com, you know, you can download it for a desktop,|||Really excited to have you on the show, Jimmy. Well, thanks. It's great to be here. Yeah, really excited. So yeah, let me start by, I can tell the audience a little bit about Brave. Brave was started by Brendan Eich and Brian Bondy. And Brendan Eich, who a lot of you will know from Mozilla, the inventor of JavaScript. And they set out to create this private by design browser, most secure, most private experience on you know, on the web. I joined, I joined actually a little over three years ago, you know, and one of the things, you know, one of the things that's really interesting about Brave, and if you haven't tried it out, please go to brave.com, you know, you can download it for a desktop,
for, you know, Android, for iOS, for, you know, for whatever you're using. You know, easy to install, easy to try out. The experience is, if you're, you know, if you use Chrome, the experience is a lot like that, except, you know, incredibly aggressive about blocking out these, you know, third-party ads and trackers that, you know, in, in, in incredibly aggressive about blocking out these, you know, third, third party ads and trackers that, you know, sort of, uh, you know, choke the internet experience and, you know, make it less private, you know, and so brave is, is this, you know, an incredibly
for, you know, Android, for iOS, for, you://for whatever you're using. You know, easy to install, easy to try out. The experience is, if you're, you know, if you use Chrome, the experience is a lot like that, except, you know, incredibly aggressive about blocking out these, you know, third-party ads and trackers that, you know, in, in, in incredibly aggressive about blocking out these, you know, third, third party ads and trackers that, you know, sort of, uh, you know, choke the internet experience and, you know, make it less private, you know, and so brave is, is this, you know, an incredibly|||for, you know, Android, for iOS, for, you://for whatever you're using. You know, easy to install, easy to try out. The experience is, if you're, you know, if you use Chrome, the experience is a lot like that, except, you know, incredibly aggressive about blocking out these, you://third-party ads and trackers that, you://in, in, in incredibly aggressive about blocking out these, you://third, third party ads and trackers that, you://sort of, uh, you://choke the internet experience and, you://make it less private, you://and so brave is, is this, you://an incredibly
fast, incredibly, uh, you know, lightweight way to, you know, enjoy the web. How did you get, you know, what, tell us a little bit about the path that, that you followed, you know, tell us a little bit about the path that you followed, you know, kind of your kind of career. Like, what was the path that kind of led you to working on Brave? Yeah, so I met Brendan Eich back when I very private by design ad systems, you know, how would you you know, how would you go about doing that? And because my background, I did my Ph.D. in privacy preserving machine learning, you know, at UCF, you know, here in Orlando. So, you know, always had this, like, real strong interest in privacy, and then got actually into, you know, advertising technology, you know, all that stuff that, you know, powers these ads. And, but there was a lot of foresight there, because I think, you know, that was probably, what, like 2010 or so. And I don't
fast, incredibly, uh, you know, lightweight way to, you know, enjoy the web. How did you get, you know, what, tell us a little bit about the path that, that you followed, you know, tell us a little bit about the path that you followed, you know, kind of your kind of career. Like, what was the path that kind of led you to working on Brave? Yeah, so I met Brendan Eich back when I very private by design ad systems, you know, how would you you know, how would you go about doing that? And because my background, I did my Ph.D. in privacy preserving machine learning, you know, at UCF, you know, here in Orlando. So, you know, always had this, like, real strong interest in privacy, and then got actually into, you know, advertising technology, you know, all that stuff that, you know, powers these ads. And, but there was a lot of foresight there, because I think, you know, that was probably, what, like 2010 or so. And I don'|||fast, incredibly, uh, you know, lightweight way to, you know, enjoy the web. How did you get, you know, what, tell us a little bit about the path that, that you followed, you know, tell us a little bit about the path that you followed, you know, kind of your kind of career. Like, what was the path that kind of led you to working on Brave? Yeah, so I met Brendan Eich back when I very private by design ad systems, you know, how would you you know, how would you go about doing that? And because my background, I did my Ph.D. in privacy preserving machine learning, you know, at UCF, you know, here in Orlando. So, you know, always had this, like, real strong interest in privacy, and then got actually into, you://advertising technology, you://all that stuff that, you://powers these ads. And, but there was a lot of foresight there, because I think, you://that was probably, what, like 2010 or so. And I don'
know if privacy, I mean, definitely privacy wasn't as big as it is now. And in general, I don't feel like it was in the zeitgeist back then. So that's very forward thinking. No, you're absolutely right. Because when my advisor came to me and said, oh, okay, well, I have this really interesting area.'s like you know privacy and data mining and i'm like what are you know what what are all those things like why does you know anybody need all that stuff and uh you know but but got into this you know really interesting area of you know because of all you know had that that data background it's like oh well this is like a really you know like there are these really interesting ways that people can share data that, you know, but still remain private by design, but sort of get still what they want out of those systems. And, you know, sort of this interesting kind of upcoming area.
know if privacy, I mean, definitely privacy wasn't as big as it is now. And in general, I don't feel like it was in the zeitgeist back then. So that's very forward thinking. No, you're absolutely right. Because when my advisor came to me and said, oh, okay, well, I have this really interesting area.'s like you know privacy and data mining and i'm like what are you know what what are all those things like why does you know anybody need all that stuff and uh you know but but got into this you know really interesting area of you know because of all you know had that that data background it's like oh well this is like a really you know like there are these really interesting ways that people can share data that, you know, but still remain private by design, but sort of get still what they want out of those systems. And, you know, sort of this interesting kind of upcoming area.|||know if privacy, I mean, definitely privacy wasn't as big as it is now. And in general, I don't feel like it was in the zeitgeist back then. So that's very forward thinking. No, you're absolutely right. Because when my advisor came to me and said, oh, okay, well, I have this really interesting area.'s like you know privacy and data mining and i'm like what are you know what what are all those things like why does you know anybody need all that stuff and uh you know but but got into this you know really interesting area of you know because of all you know had that that data background it's like oh well this is like a really you know like there are these really interesting ways that people can share data that, you know, but still remain private by design, but sort of get still what they want out of those systems. And, you know, sort of this interesting kind of upcoming area.
And actually, my first job, you know, out of my, was with a company that was just doing just that. We're saying like, Hey, you know, like great. There's all this, this advertising stuff that, you know, helps, helps power these, these publishers and, you know, keep this great content free. But we should make it more private by design and, you know, really got into that stuff. And yeah, this was, this is like 2010, 2011. And we just sort of, you know, we're like, this is, this is privacy's moment, you know, everybody's, you know, like Safari, you know, started, you know, blocking, you know, third party cookies, and like, you know, really, you know, cleaning things up. And, you know, everybody was, was, was, was starting to, you
And actually, my first job, you know, out of my, was with a company that was just doing just that. We're saying like, Hey, you know, like great. There's all this, this advertising stuff that, you know, helps, helps power these, these publishers and, you know, keep this great content free. But we should make it more private by design and, you://really got into that stuff. And yeah, this was, this is like 2010, 2011. And we just sort of, you://know, were like, this is, this is privacy's moment, you://everybody's, you://like Safari, you://started, you://blocking, you://third party cookies, and like, you://really, you://cleaning things up. And, you://everybody was, was, was, was starting to, you|||And actually, my first job, you know, out of my, was with a company that was just doing just that. We're saying like, Hey, you know, like great. There's all this, this advertising stuff that, you know, helps, helps power these, these publishers and, you://keep this great content free. But we should make it more private by design and, you://really got into that stuff. And yeah, this was, this is like 2010, 2011. And we just sort of, you://know, were like, this is, this is privacy's moment, you://everybody's, you://like Safari, you://started, you://blocking, you://third party cookies, and like, you://really, you://cleaning things up. And, you://everybody was, was, was, was starting to, you
know, kind of talk about this, like, okay, like, there's this very privacy sensitive future where, you know, you still want, you still want all the services you're accustomed to, which, you know, you don't want your data everywhere. And, and, you know, then at the time, it was sort of like, okay, people are interested. And then, you know, they say, Oh, that's, that's interesting. And doing, you know, building things that are private by design is, it's, it's, it's a lot of work. You really have to start to think about things differently and structure things differently. But we put the effort into it. And it was just kind of like, yeah, it was interesting to people, but it wasn't quite
know, kind of talk about this, like, okay, like, there's this very privacy sensitive future where, you know, you still want, you still want all the services you're accustomed to, which, you know, you don't want your data everywhere. And, and, you know, then at the time, it was sort of like, okay, people are interested. And then, you know, they say, Oh, that's, that's interesting. And doing, you know, building things that are private by design is, it's, it's, it's a lot of work. You really have to start to think about things differently and structure things differently. But we put the effort into it. And it was just kind of like, yeah, it was interesting to people, but it wasn't quite|||know, kind of talk about this, like, okay, like, there's this very privacy sensitive future where, you know, you still want, you still want all the services you're accustomed to, which, you know, you don't want your data everywhere. And, and, you know, then at the time, it was sort of like, okay, people are interested. And then, you know, they say, Oh, that's, that's interesting. And doing, you know, building things that are private by design is, it's, it's, it's a lot of work. You really have to start to think about things differently and structure things differently. But we put the effort into it. And it was just kind of like, yeah, it was interesting to people, but it wasn't quite
the time. I think fast forward 10 or so years later, and. And, and now, you know, things are really reaching fever pitch, like, you know, people realize that, that, you know, okay, look, even if we, you know, even if we trust these companies, and, you know, we don't always like how they're using our data, you know, they can be breached, you know, all these things can can happen with this data or be used in ways that we don't intend that, you know, it's, it felt like, you know, all these things can can happen with this data or be used in ways that we don't intend that, you know, it's it felt like, you know, feels like, look, this is really the time to start to, you know, push on these really private by design systems and make them work for, you know, for real. Yeah, I mean, one of the things we talked about in back in episode 109, we had Kevin Ruttia on the show and he talked about digital marketing. And it blew my mind when he went through so many different use cases of advertising and marketing. And I didn't even realize that I was being marketed to. So I'll give you one example.
the time. I think fast forward 10 or so years later, and. And, and now, you know, things are really reaching fever pitch, like, you know, people realize that, that, you know, okay, look, even if we, you know, even if we trust these companies, and, you know, we don't always like how they're using our data, you know, they can be breached, you know, all these things can can happen with this data or be used in ways that we don't intend that, you know, it's, it felt like, you know, all these things can can happen with this data or be used in ways that we don't intend that, you know, it's it felt like, you know, feels like, look, this is really the time to start to, you know, push on these really private by design systems and make them work for, you know, for real. Yeah, I mean, one of the things we talked about in back in episode 109, we had Kevin Ruttia on the show and he talked about digital marketing. And it blew my mind when he went through so many different use cases of advertising and marketing. And I didn't even realize that I was being marketed to. So I'll give you one example.|||the time. I think fast forward 10 or so years later, and. And, and now, you know, things are really reaching fever pitch, like, you know, people realize that, that, you know, okay, look, even if we, you know, even if we trust these companies, and, you know, we don't always like how they're using our data, you know, they can be breached, you know, all these things can can happen with this data or be used in ways that we don't intend that, you know, it's, it felt like, you know, all these things can can happen with this data or be used in ways that we don't intend that, you know, it's it felt like, you know, feels like, look, this is really the time to start to, you://push on these really private by design systems and make them work for, you://for real. Yeah, I mean, one of the things we talked about in back in episode 109, we had Kevin Ruttia on the show and he talked about digital marketing. And it blew my mind when he went through so many different use cases of advertising and marketing. And I didn't even realize that I was being marketed to. So I'll give you one example.
Have you ever looked up, you know, get data from, you know, I don't know, PagerDuty into Google Cloud or like, you know, something like that, or get data from Google Cloud into S3. So this company Zapier, you know, basically bought domains and did a ton of SEO. So that anytime you put, you know, get X from Y into Z, you know, basically bought domains and did a ton of SEO. So that anytime you put, you know, get X from Y into Z, you know, they've covered, they've enumerated all of those,
Have you ever looked up, you know, get data from, you know, I don't know, PagerDuty into Google Cloud or like, you know, something like that, or get data from Google Cloud into S3. So this company Zapier, you know, basically bought domains and did a ton of SEO. So that anytime you put, you know, get X from Y into Z, you know, basically bought domains and did a ton of SEO. So that anytime you put, you know, get X from Y into Z, you know, they've covered, they've enumerated all of those,|||Have you ever looked up, you know, get data from, you://I don't know, PagerDuty into Google Cloud or like, you://something like that, or get data from Google Cloud into S3. So this company Zapier, you://basically bought domains and did a ton of SEO. So that anytime you put, you://get X from Y into Z, you://basically bought domains and did a ton of SEO. So that anytime you put, you://get X from Y into Z, you://they've covered, they've enumerated all of those,
and they're the first search result. And it just seems like, wow, Zapier does everything. And so that's marketing, and it's brilliant. And it, you know, when Zapier started, they had that idea of they wanted to be the company to do that. But, you know, if I, you know, technologist who has zero marketing advertising experience had that idea, I would just build it and put it on GitHub and probably no one would even know it was there. But Zapier, you know, they put their marketing hat on and they did that and they were able to provide a ton of value to people. Right. And so folks out there, you know, you're going to be building projects and there's going to be, you know, you're going to be building projects and there's
and they're the first search result. And it just seems like, wow, Zapier does everything. And so that's marketing, and it's brilliant. And it, you know, when Zapier started, they had that idea of they wanted to be the company to do that. But, you know, if I, you know, technologist who has zero marketing advertising experience had that idea, I would just build it and put it on GitHub and probably no one would even know it was there. But Zapier, you know, they put their marketing hat on and they did that and they were able to provide a ton of value to people. Right. And so folks out there, you know, you're going to be building projects and there's going to be, you know, you're going to be building projects and there's|||and they're the first search result. And it just seems like, wow, Zapier does everything. And so that's marketing, and it's brilliant. And it, you know, when Zapier started, they had that idea of they wanted to be the company to do that. But, you know, if I, you know, technologist who has zero marketing advertising experience had that idea, I would just build it and put it on GitHub and probably no one would even know it was there. But Zapier, you know, they put their marketing hat on and they did that and they were able to provide a ton of value to people. Right. And so folks out there, you know, you're going to be building projects and there's going to be, you know, you're going to be building projects and there's
going to be, you know, an audience that really wants to consume that project, but it's not, it's not trivial to connect yourself to those people and add that value. And that is where, you know, that's, that's, that's where something like, you know, you need to have some arbitrator that knows, you know, who's looking for what and who's providing that and connects those people together. It's super, super important. So, you know, when a lot of people see ads, they see. They immediately like think of the worst things like, look at like like look what this mom feeds her kids and her kids are six foot six or whatever. It's like, you know, buy this broccoli supplement or whatever.
going to be, you know, an audience that really wants to consume that project, but it's not, it's not trivial to connect yourself to those people and add that value. And that is where, you know, that's, that's, that's where something like, you know, you need to have some arbitrator that knows, you know, who's looking for what and who's providing that and connects those people together. It's super, super important. So, you know, when a lot of people see ads, they see. They immediately like think of the worst things like, look at like like look what this mom feeds her kids and her kids are six foot six or whatever. It's like, you know, buy this broccoli supplement or whatever.|||going to be, you know, an audience that really wants to consume that project, but it's not, it's not trivial to connect yourself to those people and add that value. And that is where, you know, that's, that's, that's where something like, you://you need to have some arbitrator that knows, you://who's looking for what and who's providing that and connects those people together. It's super, super important. So, you://when a lot of people see ads, they see. They immediately like think of the worst things like, look at like like look what this mom feeds her kids and her kids are six foot six or whatever. It's like, you://buy this broccoli supplement or whatever.
Save money on your car insurance, right? Like this one weird trick and like, you know, you two could get a PhD, you know, and it's like, okay. But, but, but no, I mean that, you know, that, you know, there's also, I mean, and then on the other side of it, there's people who say, okay, there's something sinister going on here because I talked about going kayaking and the next week I'm getting a kayaking ad. Like how did that possibly happen? So it's kind of, you see the ends of the spectrum and it's important for people to realize like in
Save money on your car insurance, right? Like this one weird trick and like, you know, you two could get a PhD, you know, and it's like, okay. But, but, but no, I mean that, you know, that, you know, there's also, I mean, and then on the other side of it, there's people who say, okay, there's something sinister going on here because I talked about going kayaking and the next week I'm getting a kayaking ad. Like how did that possibly happen? So it's kind of, you see the ends of the spectrum and it's important for people to realize like in|||Save money on your car insurance, right? Like this one weird trick and like, you know, you two could get a PhD, you know, and it's like, okay. But, but, but no, I mean that, you know, that, you know, there's also, I mean, and then on the other side of it, there's people who say, okay, there's something sinister going on here because I talked about going kayaking and the next week I'm getting a kayaking ad. Like how did that possibly happen? So it's kind of, you see the ends of the spectrum and it's important for people to realize like in
between there, you know, there's a ton of value and there's the grease that keeps like our entire economy and our entire economy of knowledge and of ideas, you know, functioning. Yeah, that know, right. And of course, supporting your favorite creators and publishers, you know, that like, that's, that's actually an important part of what keeps the web going. And so, you know, yes, Brave is aggressive at blocking out these sort of third party ads and trackers and things that are doing stuff that users just don't expect or understand or, you know, sharing in a way, but it's, it's not because we're unfriendly to the internet advertising model and quite the opposite. Like we know it's, you know, that like core to, you know, like when, when Brave was founded, it's like, okay, here's the important triangle, right? Like there's the user, you know, the user is this most important part of,
between there, you know, there's a ton of value and there's the grease that keeps like our entire economy and our entire economy of knowledge and of ideas, you know, functioning. Yeah, that know, right. And of course, supporting your favorite creators and publishers, you know, that like, that's, that's actually an important part of what keeps the web going. And so, you know, yes, Brave is aggressive at blocking out these sort of third party ads and trackers and things that are doing stuff that users just don't expect or understand or, you know, sharing in a way, but it's, it's not because we're unfriendly to the internet advertising model and quite the opposite. Like we know it's, you know, that like core to, you know, like when, when Brave was founded, it's like, okay, here's the important triangle, right? Like there's the user, you know, the user is this most important part of,|||between there, you know, there's a ton of value and there's the grease that keeps like our entire economy and our entire economy of knowledge and of ideas, you know, functioning. Yeah, that know, right. And of course, supporting your favorite creators and publishers, you know, that like, that's, that's actually an important part of what keeps the web going. And so, you://yes, Brave is aggressive at blocking out these sort of third party ads and trackers and things that are doing stuff that users just don't expect or understand or, you://sharing in a way, but it's, it's not because we're unfriendly to the internet advertising model and quite the opposite. Like we know it's, you://that like core to, you://like when, when Brave was founded, it's like, okay, here's the important triangle, right? Like there's the user, you://the user is this most important part of,
of keeping the internet going. There's the advertisers who, you know, help fund it. And then there's the, there's the creators who are you know, help fund it. And then there's the there's the creators who are creating this, you know, great and interesting content that people want to go see. And they all, you know, interact importantly, you know, so and that's what, you know, and that's what really brought me to Brave and was, you know, really interesting to me. And I, you know, I said, Hey, I've got background and experience this, you know, making these systems sort of private by design and being, you know, I said, Hey, I've, I've got background and experience this, you know, making these systems sort of private by design and, and being, you know, good and transparent and above board.
of keeping the internet going. There's the advertisers who, you know, help fund it. And then there's the, there's the creators who are you know, help fund it. And then there's the there's the creators who are creating this, you know, great and interesting content that people want to go see. And they all, you know, interact importantly, you know, so and that's what, you know, and that's what really brought me to Brave and was, you know, really interesting to me. And I, you know, I said, Hey, I've got background and experience this, you know, making these systems sort of private by design and being, you know, I said, Hey, I've, I've got background and experience this, you know, making these systems sort of private by design and, and being, you know, good and transparent and above board.|||of keeping the internet going. There's the advertisers who, you know, help fund it. And then there's the, there's the creators who are you know, help fund it. And then there's the there's the creators who are creating this, you know, great and interesting content that people want to go see. And they all, you know, interact importantly, you know, so and that's what, you know, and that's what really brought me to Brave and was, you know, really interesting to me. And I, you://I said, Hey, I've got background and experience this, you://making these systems sort of private by design and being, you://I said, Hey, I've, I've got background and experience this, you://making these systems sort of private by design and, and being, you://good and transparent and above board.
And, and, and let's, let's do this. Let's make this a part of it. Um, because yeah, to your point, um, you know, if, if you've tried to visit, um, you know, uh, any, any publisher site recently, you know, with, with, without brave or other, you know, comparable protections, right. Like, you know, open up, you know, without Brave or other, you know, comparable protections, right? Like, you know, open up, you know, do yourself a favor. It's like, you know, open up that inspector, like look at the network tab and, you know, see all of the requests that come along with just reading an article or, you know, going through something. And it can be dozens or hundreds of these requests
And, and, and let's, let's do this. Let's make this a part of it. Um, because yeah, to your point, um, you know, if, if you've tried to visit, um, you know, uh, any, any publisher site recently, you know, with, with, without brave or other, you know, comparable protections, right. Like, you know, open up, you know, without Brave or other, you know, comparable protections, right? Like, you know, open up, you know, do yourself a favor. It's like, you know, open up that inspector, like look at the network tab and, you know, see all of the requests that come along with just reading an article or, you know, going through something. And it can be dozens or hundreds of these requests|||And, and, and let's, let's do this. Let's make this a part of it. Um, because yeah, to your point, um, you know, if, if you've tried to visit, um, you://any publisher site recently, you://with, with, without brave or other, you://comparable protections, right. Like, you://open up, you://without Brave or other, you://comparable protections, right? Like, you://open up, you://do yourself a favor. It's like, you://open up that inspector, like look at the network tab and, you://see all of the requests that come along with just reading an article or, you://going through something. And it can be dozens or hundreds of these requests
that are sharing data about you in different ways and transferring it between systems. And again, all these things that you don't necessarily expect. If you are on, for instance, a car site, right? Well, typically on all those car sites, there are these, they call them pixels in the background. They're just, you know, little like, like invisible things that, that your, your browser will load. And they'll like, you know, set, set this cookie, set this little piece of information saying like, great, here's, here's, here's somebody and they've gone to a car site. And then you'll be on some other unrelated site they'll make a similar request from that same provider and say like oh yeah this was this was
that are sharing data about you in different ways and transferring it between systems. And again, all these things that you don't necessarily expect. If you are on, for instance, a car site, right? Well, typically on all those car sites, there are these, they call them pixels in the background. They're just, you know, little like, like invisible things that, that your, your browser will load. And they'll like, you know, set, set this cookie, set this little piece of information saying like, great, here's, here's, here's somebody and they've gone to a car site. And then you'll be on some other unrelated site they'll make a similar request from that same provider and say like oh yeah this was this was|||that are sharing data about you in different ways and transferring it between systems. And again, all these things that you don't necessarily expect. If you are on, for instance, a car site, right? Well, typically on all those car sites, there are these, they call them pixels in the background. They're just, you know, little like, like invisible things that, that your, your browser will load. And they'll like, you know, set, set this cookie, set this little piece of information saying like, great, here's, here's, here's somebody and they've gone to a car site. And then you'll be on some other unrelated site they'll make a similar request from that same provider and say like oh yeah this was this was
you know same same person who was on that uh you know on that car site and sort of this this data can you know follow you everywhere and and you know get processed in other systems and then you know people are like you know it's it's not that people always object to being advertised to, but they're like, how did you know this? Where did you get this? Yeah, and then once you introduce the social graph, so I think Twitter, Facebook, LinkedIn to a lesser extent, TikTok, I mean, all these sites have similar kind of uh pixels that they put
you know same same person who was on that uh you know on that car site and sort of this this data can you know follow you everywhere and and you know get processed in other systems and then you know people are like you know it's it's not that people always object to being advertised to, but they're like, how did you know this? Where did you get this? Yeah, and then once you introduce the social graph, so I think Twitter, Facebook, LinkedIn to a lesser extent, TikTok, I mean, all these sites have similar kind of uh pixels that they put|||you know same same person who was on that uh you know on that car site and sort of this this data can you know follow you everywhere and and you know get processed in other systems and then you know people are like you know it's it's not that people always object to being advertised to, but they're like, how did you know this? Where did you get this? Yeah, and then once you introduce the social graph, so I think Twitter, Facebook, LinkedIn to a lesser extent, TikTok, I mean, all these sites have similar kind of uh pixels that they put
on other people's sites at least the whole third party cookies thing and so what can happen is you're getting back to the kayak example i mean i definitely get got asked this a lot in the past like like you know is is is my phone listening to me 24 7 and somehow doing some asr 24 7 and then pulling out adWords. It'd be extremely intractable from a tech perspective, but, but what's actually happening there is, you know, you might've talked about kayaking to somebody and then that person went on the web and looked up a bunch of kayaking stuff. And because you and that person are such close friends, now both of you are impacted by what that person did. And so and so so anytime you have a dialogue that other persons, you know, you know, if you have a real life connection and a Facebook connection, I mean, all of that feels extremely creepy. And because the data is coming from so many different places and it's not siloed, you
on other people's sites at least the whole third party cookies thing and so what can happen is you're getting back to the kayak example i mean i definitely get got asked this a lot in the past like like you know is is is my phone listening to me 24 7 and somehow doing some asr 24 7 and then pulling out adWords. It'd be extremely intractable from a tech perspective, but, but what's actually happening there is, you know, you might've talked about kayaking to somebody and then that person went on the web and looked up a bunch of kayaking stuff. And because you and that person are such close friends, now both of you are impacted by what that person did. And so and so so anytime you have a dialogue that other persons, you know, you know, if you have a real life connection and a Facebook connection, I mean, all of that feels extremely creepy. And because the data is coming from so many different places and it's not siloed, you|||on other people's sites at least the whole third party cookies thing and so what can happen is you're getting back to the kayak example i mean i definitely get got asked this a lot in the past like like you know is is is my phone listening to me 24 7 and somehow doing some asr 24 7 and then pulling out adWords. It'd be extremely intractable from a tech perspective, but, but what's actually happening there is, you know, you might've talked about kayaking to somebody and then that person went on the web and looked up a bunch of kayaking stuff. And because you and that person are such close friends, now both of you are impacted by what that person did. And so and so so anytime you have a dialogue that other persons, you know, you know, if you have a real life connection and a Facebook connection, I mean, all of that feels extremely creepy. And because the data is coming from so many different places and it's not siloed, you
know, it feels like there's something sinister, you know, some, some evil magic going on. And, and really what we need is, is to your point is we just need to be able to silo things, you know, and, and I think the blocking of the third-party cookies, that's a relatively recent thing, right? I mean, Brave has pretty aggressive protections, I think, from day one. But yeah, a lot of them, you know, it's, it's, you know, Google Chrome is, is trying to, you know, do away with these, you know, sort of third party cookies by default. Yeah, they're feeling not just from like users and lawmakers and people like that, but from, you know, from industry, from like people who want to advertise stuff, they're like, okay, well, this, this is fine if we have to find a more
know, it feels like there's something sinister, you know, some, some evil magic going on. And, and really what we need is, is to your point is we just need to be able to silo things, you know, and, and I think the blocking of the third-party cookies, that's a relatively recent thing, right? I mean, Brave has pretty aggressive protections, I think, from day one. But yeah, a lot of them, you know, it's, it's, you know, Google Chrome is, is trying to, you know, do away with these, you know, sort of third party cookies by default. Yeah, they're feeling not just from like users and lawmakers and people like that, but from, you know, from industry, from like people who want to advertise stuff, they're like, okay, well, this, this is fine if we have to find a more|||know, it feels like there's something sinister, you know, some, some evil magic going on. And, and really what we need is, is to your point is we just need to be able to silo things, you know, and, and I think the blocking of the third-party cookies, that's a relatively recent thing, right? I mean, Brave has pretty aggressive protections, I think, from day one. But yeah, a lot of them, you know, it's, it's, you know, Google Chrome is, is trying to, you know, do away with these, you know, sort of third party cookies by default. Yeah, they're feeling not just from like users and lawmakers and people like that, but from, you know, from industry, from like people who want to advertise stuff, they're like, okay, well, this, this is fine if we have to find a more
private way to do it, but like, we, we, we got to get started, you know, we we've got to, you know, we've got to start using these, these better ways of doing it, or we're going to, you know, lose access to, you know, to our audiences. Yeah, that makes sense. So from like a, a tech standpoint, can you kind of walk folks through, you know, what are sort of third party cookies and then, and what does Brave do and how is, how is that different? Like what, what actually, you know, at the end of the day you still want to learn uh people's interests right like i don't want to see ads for i don't know knitting or something like that like i'd rather see something that that is going to be relevant to me that that is i saw an ad recently for um um um for this for this uh kind of like a
private way to do it, but like, we, we, we got to get started, you know, we we've got to, you know, we've got to start using these, these better ways of doing it, or we're going to, you know, lose access to, you know, to our audiences. Yeah, that makes sense. So from like a, a tech standpoint, can you kind of walk folks through, you know, what are sort of third party cookies and then, and what does Brave do and how is, how is that different? Like what, what actually, you know, at the end of the day you still want to learn uh people's interests right like i don't want to see ads for i don't know knitting or something like that like i'd rather see something that that is going to be relevant to me that that is i saw an ad recently for um um um for this for this uh kind of like a|||private way to do it, but like, we, we, we got to get started, you know, we we've got to, you know, we've got to start using these, these better ways of doing it, or we're going to, you know, lose access to, you://to our audiences. Yeah, that makes sense. So from like a, a tech standpoint, can you kind of walk folks through, you know, what are sort of third party cookies and then, and what does Brave do and how is, how is that different? Like what, what actually, you know, at the end of the day you still want to learn uh people's interests right like i don't want to see ads for i don't know knitting or something like that like i'd rather see something that that is going to be relevant to me that that is i saw an ad recently for um um um for this for this uh kind of like a
product that anyways it's kind of like a product that, anyways, it's kind of a technical thing, but I thought, oh, this is really cool. I could probably use this. And so that's the kind of thing that you want. And so, you know, how does, you know, what was the state of things before Brave? And what is Brave doing?
product that anyways it's kind of like a product that, anyways, it's kind of a technical thing, but I thought, oh, this is really cool. I could probably use this. And so that's the kind of thing that you want. And so, you know, how does, you know, what was the state of things before Brave? And what is Brave doing?|||product that anyways it's kind of like a product that, anyways, it's kind of a technical thing, but I thought, oh, this is really cool. I could probably use this. And so that's the kind of thing that you want. And so, you know, how does, you know, what was the state of things before Brave? And what is Brave doing?
And how do you kind of, can you get the best of both worlds? Or how do you deal with that dialectic? Sure thing. I mean, and look, let me caveat by saying I am not the expert in Brave's various protections. There are people who are great at it at Brave. And they can speak to you at length about the numerous, numerous fine-grained protections that Brave offers, all the way from sort of blocking these requests as far upstream as you can to preventing fingerprinting, which is when
And how do you kind of, can you get the best of both worlds? Or how do you deal with that dialectic? Sure thing. I mean, and look, let me caveat by saying I am not the expert in Brave's various protections. There are people who are great at it at Brave. And they can speak to you at length about the numerous, numerous fine-grained protections that Brave offers, all the way from sort of blocking these requests as far upstream as you can to preventing fingerprinting, which is when|||And how do you kind of, can you get the best of both worlds? Or how do you deal with that dialectic? Sure thing. I mean, and look, let me caveat by saying I am not the expert in Brave's various protections. There are people who are great at it at Brave. And they can speak to you at length about the numerous, numerous fine-grained protections that Brave offers, all the way from sort of blocking these requests as far upstream as you can to preventing fingerprinting, which is when
advertisers sort of use unique information about your device, even when they can't set cookies. There's these numerous protections they can write books for you on, you know, but I mean, yeah, what it comes down to is like different ways of, you know, protecting your information from getting, you know, shared like across sites, across sessions, across things that you do. So in that example that I talked about, you know, where you are, you know, like I said, on a car site, right, or on a travel site, and sort of your, whatever you're doing there, your preferences on that are then being pulled back into this ad tech provider's kind of infrastructure, right? And then, and it is a third party request.
advertisers sort of use unique information about your device, even when they can't set cookies. There's these numerous protections they can write books for you on, you know, but I mean, yeah, what it comes down to is like different ways of, you know, protecting your information from getting, you know, shared like across sites, across sessions, across things that you do. So in that example that I talked about, you know, where you are, you know, like I said, on a car site, right, or on a travel site, and sort of your, whatever you're doing there, your preferences on that are then being pulled back into this ad tech provider's kind of infrastructure, right? And then, and it is a third party request.|||advertisers sort of use unique information about your device, even when they can't set cookies. There's these numerous protections they can write books for you on, you://but I mean, yeah, what it comes down to is like different ways of, you://protecting your information from getting, you://shared like across sites, across sessions, across things that you do. So in that example that I talked about, you://where you are, you://like I said, on a car site, right, or on a travel site, and sort of your, whatever you're doing there, your preferences on that are then being pulled back into this ad tech provider's kind of infrastructure, right? And then, and it is a third party request.
If you're on travelwhatever.com, this is to, you know, goes to ad tech provider.com. But, you know, they know it's coming from that travel site. And so, you know, then you can, you know, if you are on at some later point, you're on a news site, right? And that new site wants to serve you ads. All it has to do is say, make a request to, you know, adtechprovider.com. It says, oh, actually, this is somebody I recognize,
If you're on travelwhatever.com, this is to, you know, goes to ad tech provider.com. But, you know, they know it's coming from that travel site. And so, you know, then you can, you know, if you are on at some later point, you're on a news site, right? And that new site wants to serve you ads. All it has to do is say, make a request to, you know, adtechprovider.com. It says, oh, actually, this is somebody I recognize,|||If you're on travelwhatever.com, this is to, you know, goes to ad tech provider.com. But, you know, they know it's coming from that travel site. And so, you know, then you can, you know, if you are on at some later point, you're on a news site, right? And that new site wants to serve you ads. All it has to do is say, make a request to, you://adtechprovider.com. It says, oh, actually, this is somebody I recognize,
like somebody I recognize, and I know they've done some interesting and relevant, you know, I know they're interested in travel, you know, I know they've looked up some new cars, you know, whatever it is, and then say, and I, you know, and have those ads to give you right there. But, you know, and uh you know and to your point it's like look you you want stuff to be relevant sometimes and sometimes you like like as as jaded as we can become about you know advertising on the internet it's like oh that's that's a cool thing like i didn't not like that's great why didn't you tell me that existed like now i want that you know and so right and put yourself on the other side of it. I mean, if you build something, you know, how are you going to tell someone halfway
like somebody I recognize, and I know they've done some interesting and relevant, you know, I know they're interested in travel, you know, I know they've looked up some new cars, you know, whatever it is, and then say, and I, you know, and have those ads to give you right there. But, you know, and uh you know and to your point it's like look you you want stuff to be relevant sometimes and sometimes you like like as as jaded as we can become about you know advertising on the internet it's like oh that's that's a cool thing like i didn't not like that's great why didn't you tell me that existed like now i want that you know and so right and put yourself on the other side of it. I mean, if you build something, you know, how are you going to tell someone halfway|||like somebody I recognize, and I know they've done some interesting and relevant, you://I know they're interested in travel, you://I know they've looked up some new cars, you://whatever it is, and then say, and I, you://and have those ads to give you right there. But, you://and uh you://and to your point it's like look you you want stuff to be relevant sometimes and sometimes you like like as as jaded as we can become about you://advertising on the internet it's like oh that's that's a cool thing like i didn't not like that's great why didn't you tell me that existed like now i want that you://and so right and put yourself on the other side of it. I mean, if you build something, you://how are you going to tell someone halfway
across the world about your thing? That's right. And there's really no other, other way to do it. I mean, that's, that's what people have done since, since the dawn of, uh, of, of, of, of commerce, right? Yeah. And if you're, you know, and if you're a publisher, right. And, and that's, and, and that's, you know, very much part of the conversation, like you actually want, you know, that's, that's how in a ton of cases you're, you're funding, you know, the content that you're putting together. Like, yeah, you know, people are paywalling stuff more, but like the, you know, sort of the easiest way to get, get things out there. And the reason why, you know, a lot of small creators can
across the world about your thing? That's right. And there's really no other, other way to do it. I mean, that's, that's what people have done since, since the dawn of, uh, of, of, of, of commerce, right? Yeah. And if you're, you know, and if you're a publisher, right. And, and that's, and, and that's, you know, very much part of the conversation, like you actually want, you know, that's, that's how in a ton of cases you're, you're funding, you know, the content that you're putting together. Like, yeah, you know, people are paywalling stuff more, but like the, you know, sort of the easiest way to get, get things out there. And the reason why, you know, a lot of small creators can|||across the world about your thing? That's right. And there's really no other, other way to do it. I mean, that's, that's what people have done since, since the dawn of, uh, of, of, of, of commerce, right? Yeah. And if you're, you know, and if you're a publisher, right. And, and that's, and, and that's, you://very much part of the conversation, like you actually want, you://that's, that's how in a ton of cases you're, you're funding, you://the content that you're putting together. Like, yeah, you://people are paywalling stuff more, but like the, you://sort of the easiest way to get, get things out there. And the reason why, you://a lot of small creators can
exist is, is that, you know, ability to advertise and, and, and, and get, you know, sort of get rewarded for, for what they do. Right. And so, you know, that's, that's an important component of it. Or, you know, we're fine, you know, right. It's important that they find ways that they can, you know, in a, in a low friction way, get, you know, get support from their community. And it's, you know, people aren't always into, you know, okay, well pull out, you know, my, my credit card and, you know, put, put in 10 bucks there. And, you know, that's, it's, it's sometimes that's very high friction for them to do. And so, you know, that's, that's, like I said, another piece of that. And so the, the alternative that, you know, Brave has put in a lot of effort to,
exist is, is that, you know, ability to advertise and, and, and, and get, you know, sort of get rewarded for, for what they do. Right. And so, you know, that's, that's an important component of it. Or, you know, we're fine, you know, right. It's important that they find ways that they can, you know, in a, in a low friction way, get, you know, get support from their community. And it's, you know, people aren't always into, you know, okay, well pull out, you know, my, my credit card and, you know, put, put in 10 bucks there. And, you know, that's, it's, it's sometimes that's very high friction for them to do. And so, you know, that's, that's, like I said, another piece of that. And so the, the alternative that, you, (breath) brave has put in a lot of effort to,|||exist is, is that, you://ability to advertise and, and, and, and get, you://sort of get rewarded for, for what they do. Right. And so, you://that's, that's an important component of it. Or, you://we're fine, you://right. It's important that they find ways that they can, you://in a, in a low friction way, get, you://get support from their community. And it's, you://people aren't always into, you://okay, well pull out, you://my, my credit card and, you://put, put in 10 bucks there. And, you://that's, it's, it's sometimes that's very high friction for them to do. And so, you://that's, that's, like I said, another piece of that. And so the, the alternative that, you://(breath) brave has put in a lot of effort to,
you know, looks a lot like this, right? So we work, you know, we work with advertisers also, right? And so we say, you know, they come to us and they say, yeah, we've got this great new project. We, you know, we want to get this, you know, in front of people, you know, all that other good stuff. Okay, well, we have an interface where they can put in and call it trafficking a campaign, but it's basically saying, okay, what do you want to tell them? Where do you want to send them? And how much do you want to spend? And then for users who opt in to what we call, it's a brave rewards program. And the part that I work on is Brave Ads. And so users opt into this. They decide to do this. They say, yes, want to do this. And the great part about it is they're rewarded for their
you, (breath) looks a lot like this, right? So we work, you, (breath) we work with advertisers also, right? And so we say, you, (breath) they come to us and they say, yeah, we've got this great new project. We, you, (breath) we want to get this, you, (breath) in front of people, you, (breath) all that other good stuff. Okay, well, we have an interface where they can put in and call it trafficking a campaign, but it's basically saying, okay, what do you want to tell them? Where do you want to send them? And how much do you want to spend? And then for users who opt in to what we call, it's a brave rewards program. And the part that I work on is Brave Ads. And so users opt into this. They decide to do this. They say, yes, want to do this. And the great part about it is they're rewarded for their|||you, (breath) looks a lot like this, right? So we work, you, (breath) we work with advertisers also, right? And so we say, you, (breath) they come to us and they say, yeah, we've got this great new project. We, you, (breath) we want to get this, you, (breath) in front of people, you, (breath) all that other good stuff. Okay, well, we have an interface where they can put in and call it trafficking a campaign, but it's basically saying, okay, what do you want to tell them? Where do you want to send them? And how much do you want to spend? And then for users who opt in to what we call, it's a brave rewards program. And the part that I work on is Brave Ads. And so users opt into this. They decide to do this. They say, yes, want to do this. And the great part about it is they're rewarded for their
attention. They get 70% of the ads revenue that we take in is paid out directly to them in the form of our basic attention token. It's Ethereum based crypto token that can transfer value. It's got real worth. And so you opt into this program and then what's happening in the background is this. Your browser then goes out, fetches this catalog of ads for your region of all, all the stuff that advertisers, you know, are you going to show you. And then as you browse along, we're using what you know, we call it local machine learning. So that means that everything stays on device, right? Like, you know, your
attention. They get 70% of the ads revenue that we take in is paid out directly to them in the form of our basic attention token. It's Ethereum based crypto token that can transfer value. It's got real worth. And so you opt into this program and then what's happening in the background is this. Your browser then goes out, fetches this catalog of ads for your region of all, all the stuff that advertisers, you know, are you going to show you. And then as you browse along, we're using what you know, we call it local machine learning. So that means that everything stays on device, right? Like, you know, your|||attention. They get 70% of the ads revenue that we take in is paid out directly to them in the form of our basic attention token. It's Ethereum based crypto token that can transfer value. It's got real worth. And so you opt into this program and then what's happening in the background is this. Your browser then goes out, fetches this catalog of ads for your region of all, all the stuff that advertisers, you know, are you going to show you. And then as you browse along, we're using what you know, we call it local machine learning. So that means that everything stays on device, right? Like, you know, your
history, your visits, your searches, they they never get sent to, they never get sent, they, they never get sent to, they never get sent to Brave. They never get sent to anybody else. All that stuff happened, happens with you, but we can still make stuff relevant by saying, oh, okay, well, you know, the browser itself saying like, okay, well, what are they interested in? All right. Well, they've been browsing these, you know, like they're looking for a new laptop, like, okay, great. Like we can, you know, you can recognize that and you never have to communicate that, you know, to Brave or anybody else's systems. But then your browser said, okay, actually I'm looking in this big list of ads and there's
history, your visits, your searches, they they never get sent to, they never get sent, they, they never get sent to, they never get sent to Brave. They never get sent to anybody else. All that stuff happened, happens with you, but we can still make stuff relevant by saying, oh, okay, well, you know, the browser itself saying like, okay, well, what are they interested in? All right. Well, they've been browsing these, you know, like they're looking for a new laptop, like, okay, great. Like we can, you know, you can recognize that and you never have to communicate that, you know, to Brave or anybody else's systems. But then your browser said, okay, actually I'm looking in this big list of ads and there's|||history, your visits, your searches, they they never get sent to, they never get sent, they, they never get sent to, they never get sent to Brave. They never get sent to anybody else. All that stuff happened, happens with you, but we can still make stuff relevant by saying, oh, okay, well, you know, the browser itself saying like, okay, well, what are they interested in? All right. Well, they've been browsing these, you know, like they're looking for a new laptop, like, okay, great. Like we can, you know, you can recognize that and you never have to communicate that, you://to Brave or anybody else's systems. But then your browser said, okay, actually I'm looking in this big list of ads and there's
something like exactly, there's like a great deal on a new laptop, right? And then we, right now in a couple of different forms, either you'll see a little notification pop up at the side. We have some that come up in a newsreader and some, you know, across, you know, the tab page. But, you know, for the notification ones, you know, those are put, you know, those are made relevant for you, right? And so it's like, okay, great. We know that we've got like a, uh, you know, exactly what they're looking for.
something like exactly, there's like a great deal on a new laptop, right? And then we, right now in a couple of different forms, either you'll see a little notification pop up at the side. We have some that come up in a newsreader and some, you know, across, you know, the tab page. But, you know, for the notification ones, you know, those are put, you know, those are made relevant for you, right? And so it's like, okay, great. We know that we've got like a, uh, you know, exactly what they're looking for.|||something like exactly, there's like a great deal on a new laptop, right? And then we, right now in a couple of different forms, either you'll see a little notification pop up at the side. We have some that come up in a newsreader and some, you://across, you://the tab page. But, you://for the notification ones, you://those are put, you://those are made relevant for you, right? And so it's like, okay, great. We know that we've got like a, uh, you://exactly what they're looking for.
Um, let's show this, let's show this to them. Right. And then what we do is this, this really interesting process from there. Um, we have, it's, it's, it's called a two-phase blinded token process, basically. Sponsor for today's show is Imparticle. At the end of the day, your customer has to be at the center of everything you do. This starts with the right customer data strategy, as well as the right foundation to solve the challenges that typically inhibit success such as data quality, data governance, and connectivity. mParticle is your real-time customer data infrastructure that helps accelerate your data strategy by cleansing, visualizing, and integrating your
Um, let's show this, let's show this to them. Right. And then what we do is this, this really interesting process from there. Um, we have, it's, it's, it's called a two-phase blinded token process, basically. Sponsor for today's show is Imparticle. At the end of the day, your customer has to be at the center of everything you do. This starts with the right customer data strategy, as well as the right foundation to solve the challenges that typically inhibit success such as data quality, data governance, and connectivity. mParticle is your real-time customer data infrastructure that helps accelerate your data strategy by cleansing, visualizing, and integrating your|||Um, let's show this, let's show this to them. Right. And then what we do is this, this really interesting process from there. Um, we have, it's, it's, it's called a two-phase blinded token process, basically. Sponsor for today's show is Imparticle. At the end of the day, your customer has to be at the center of everything you do. This starts with the right customer data strategy, as well as the right foundation to solve the challenges that typically inhibit success such as data quality, data governance, and connectivity. mParticle is your real-time customer data infrastructure that helps accelerate your data strategy by cleansing, visualizing, and integrating your
customer data from anywhere to anywhere. Ultimately, better data leads to better decisions, better customer experiences, and better outcomes. Some of the best brands in retail, financial services, hospitality, media, travel, gaming, and many other industries have chosen MParticle. Learn more by visiting www.mparticle.com. Better data, better decisions, better outcomes. Visit mparticle.com to learn how teams at Postmates, NBCUniversal, Spotify, and Airbnb use mParticle's customer data infrastructure to accelerate their customer data strategies. So like, how does that, how do you get started building something like that right because you're you're building something that you can't observe and so and so that uh seems really really hard i
customer data from anywhere to anywhere. Ultimately, better data leads to better decisions, better customer experiences, and better outcomes. Some of the best brands in retail, financial services, hospitality, media, travel, gaming, and many other industries have chosen MParticle. Learn more by visiting www.mparticle.com. Better data, better decisions, better outcomes. Visit mparticle.com to learn how teams at Postmates, NBCUniversal, Spotify, and Airbnb use mParticle's customer data infrastructure to accelerate their customer data strategies. So like, how does that, how do you get started building something like that right because you're you're building something that you can't observe and so and so that uh seems really really hard i|||customer data from anywhere to anywhere. Ultimately, better data leads to better decisions, better customer experiences, and better outcomes. Some of the best brands in retail, financial services, hospitality, media, travel, gaming, and many other industries have chosen MParticle. Learn more by visiting www.mparticle.com. Better data, better decisions, better outcomes. Visit mparticle.com to learn how teams at Postmates, NBCUniversal, Spotify, and Airbnb use mParticle's customer data infrastructure to accelerate their customer data strategies. So like, how does that, how do you get started building something like that right because you're you're building something that you can't observe and so and so that uh seems really really hard i
mean actually we could yeah let's spend a little bit of time on that i mean you have to um so so you know to backtrack a little bit so you know the way i guess you know old ad tech would work is they would they would take in, you know, so that that company you said would see, oh, you know, this person went to this travel website. And so they would have a row somewhere in some database somewhere saying, you know, Jimmy Secerton went to travel website at this time on this day. And then they have a ton of these rows. And then they can do a bunch of machine learning on that and then they can ask like little hypotheticals like okay what do i think jimmy is really
mean actually we could yeah let's spend a little bit of time on that i mean you have to um so so you know to backtrack a little bit so you know the way i guess you know old ad tech would work is they would they would take in, you know, so that that company you said would see, oh, you know, this person went to this travel website. And so they would have a row somewhere in some database somewhere saying, you know, Jimmy Secerton went to travel website at this time on this day. And then they have a ton of these rows. And then they can do a bunch of machine learning on that and then they can ask like little hypotheticals like okay what do i think jimmy is really|||mean actually we could yeah let's spend a little bit of time on that i mean you have to um so so you know to backtrack a little bit so you know the way i guess you know old ad tech would work is they would they would take in, you know, so that that company you said would see, oh, you know, this person went to this travel website. And so they would have a row somewhere in some database somewhere saying, you://Jimmy Secerton went to travel website at this time on this day. And then they have a ton of these rows. And then they can do a bunch of machine learning on that and then they can ask like little hypotheticals like okay what do i think jimmy is really
interested in now and it would come back and say laptops and they say okay well that looks like it makes sense because i have this whole database in your case though you know it's it's all blind right so so how do you build something? It just seems like wild to be able to build something like that and, and, and know that it's working. Yeah. And it is very challenging to, to put together and run, but it's, it's, it's powerful when it works, you know? So, right. Exactly. To your point, if this were traditional ad tech, you know, the, the request would go out, you know, I'd be on some new site. The request would go out to, you know, travel site or, you know, to adtechprovider.com.
interested in now and it would come back and say laptops and they say okay well that looks like it makes sense because i have this whole database in your case though you know it's it's all blind right so so how do you build something? It just seems like wild to be able to build something like that and, and, and know that it's working. Yeah. And it is very challenging to, to put together and run, but it's, it's, it's powerful when it works, you know? So, right. Exactly. To your point, if this were traditional ad tech, you know, the, the request would go out, you know, I'd be on some new site. The request would go out to, you know, travel site or, you know, to adtechprovider.com.|||interested in now and it would come back and say laptops and they say okay well that looks like it makes sense because i have this whole database in your case though you know it's it's all blind right so so how do you build something? It just seems like wild to be able to build something like that and, and, and know that it's working. Yeah. And it is very challenging to, to put together and run, but it's, it's, it's powerful when it works, you know? So, right. Exactly. To your point, if this were traditional ad tech, you know, the, the request would go out, you know, I'd be on some new site. The request would go out to, you://travel site or, you://to adtechprovider.com.
And yeah, I, you know, I, my user ID there would represent, you know, hundreds, thousands of rows in that database that, you know, covers literally everything that I, you know, might have ever shown interest in, you know, or at least since I, you know, last, last cleared my cookies. Right. And so, right. It could be like, okay, well we got laptops and, you know, we got this travel. Even then there's the fingerprinting thing. We should definitely talk about that too. I'd love to learn more about that. That's right. And so even, you know, it's like, even when, you know, you know, and I say like, okay, great, I'm going to solve this. I've blocked out third-party cookies like this. Great. It is fine. They can't use this ID to look up stuff about me. What some of these systems can then do is they say, well, okay, we know historically that it's like, you know, your IP address hangs around for, you know, X amount of time.
And yeah, I, you know, I, my user ID there would represent, you know, hundreds, thousands of rows in that database that, you know, covers literally everything that I, you know, might have ever shown interest in, you know, or at least since I, you know, last, last cleared my cookies. Right. And so, right. It could be like, okay, well we got laptops and, you know, we got this travel. Even then there's the fingerprinting thing. We should definitely talk about that too. I'd love to learn more about that. That's right. And so even, you know, it's like, even when, you know, you know, and I say like, okay, great, I'm going to solve this. I've blocked out third-party cookies like this. Great. It is fine. They can't use this ID to look up stuff about me. What some of these systems can then do is they say, well, okay, we know historically that it's like, you know, your IP address hangs around for, you://X amount of time.|||And yeah, I, you know, I, my user ID there would represent, you://hundreds, thousands of rows in that database that, you://covers literally everything that I, you://might have ever shown interest in, you://or at least since I, you://last, last cleared my cookies. Right. And so, right. It could be like, okay, well we got laptops and, you://we got this travel. Even then there's the fingerprinting thing. We should definitely talk about that too. I'd love to learn more about that. That's right. And so even, you://it's like, even when, you://you know, and I say like, okay, great, I'm going to solve this. I've blocked out third-party cookies like this. Great. It is fine. They can't use this ID to look up stuff about me. What some of these systems can then do is they say, well, okay, we know historically that it's like, you://your IP address hangs around for, you://X amount of time.
And your user agent has, you know, sort of this identifiable. It's either this or something you've recently upgraded. And it can get wild, you know. And I don't know how common these are out there. But, like, it can even go to the point where it's like how your GPU renders stuff, you know, and that can be like, like you can, you can sort of read back those like can pixels in the canvas and like different,
And your user agent has, you know, sort of this identifiable. It's either this or something you've recently upgraded. And it can get wild, you know. And I don't know how common these are out there. But, like, it can even go to the point where it's like how your GPU renders stuff, you know, and that can be like, like you can, you can sort of read back those like can pixels in the canvas and like different,|||And your user agent has, you know, sort of this identifiable. It's either this or something you've recently upgraded. And it can get wild, you know. And I don't know how common these are out there. But, like, it can even go to the point where it's like how your GPU renders stuff, you know, and that can be like, like you can, you can sort of read back those like can pixels in the canvas and like different,
different configured computers and browsers will like render things in different ways. Like it, it, it gets, you know, it gets extreme and it's, and it's a, you know, it's, it's an arms race in some, in some ways, right. Of like, okay, you know, it gets extreme and it's, and it's a, you know, it's an arms race in some, in some ways, right. Of like, okay, you know, somebody will introduce some protection against this type of, of, you know, re-identification or fingerprinting. And then, you know, somebody will come out with something even more sophisticated to, you know, to get around it. Right. Wow. That's wild. Yeah. I mean, now that I'm, you know, taking the time to think about it, I mean, a lot of people, you know, their browser doesn't occupy, they're not full screen, like the browser doesn't occupy the whole window. And so they've probably just resized it, you know, months ago, and it's just that size. And so it's some like pretty unique number. I mean, yeah, there's all sorts of things you could do, right? That's right. And each little bit of information that you have gives you a little bit more to help you, you know, identify that. So it's, even if you can't
different configured computers and browsers will like render things in different ways. Like it, it, it gets, you know, it gets extreme and it's, and it's a, you know, it's, it's an arms race in some, in some ways, right. Of like, okay, you know, it gets extreme and it's, and it's a, you know, it's an arms race in some, in some ways, right. Of like, okay, you know, somebody will introduce some protection against this type of, of, you know, re-identification or fingerprinting. And then, you know, somebody will come out with something even more sophisticated to, you know, to get around it. Right. Wow. That's wild. Yeah. I mean, now that I'm, you know, taking the time to think about it, I mean, a lot of people, you know, their browser doesn't occupy, they're not full screen, like the browser doesn't occupy the whole window. And so they've probably just resized it, you know, months ago, and it's just that size. And so it's some like pretty unique number. I mean, yeah, there's all sorts of things you could do, right? That's right. And each little bit of information that you have gives you a little bit more to help you, you know, identify that. So it's, even if you can't|||different configured computers and browsers will like render things in different ways. Like it, it, it gets, you://it gets extreme and it's, and it's a, you://it's an arms race in some, in some ways, right. Of like, okay, you://it gets extreme and it's, and it's a, you://it's an arms race in some, in some ways, right. Of like, okay, you://somebody will introduce some protection against this type of, of, you://re-identification or fingerprinting. And then, you://somebody will come out with something even more sophisticated to, you://to get around it. Right. Wow. That's wild. Yeah. I mean, now that I'm, you://taking the time to think about it, I mean, a lot of people, you://their browser doesn't occupy, they're not full screen, like the browser doesn't occupy the whole window. And so they've probably just resized it, you://months ago, and it's just that size. And so it's some like pretty unique number. I mean, yeah, there's all sorts of things you could do, right? That's right. And each little bit of information that you have gives you a little bit more to help you, you://identify that. So it's, even if you can't
set the cookies that you want to, um, you know, there's, there are systems out there that, that help, that helps her reconnect that and say like, oh, okay, actually I thought this was somebody new, but I took this, this, and this, and I pulled all this in and it's like, okay, now I've got, and it's like, now I've got, you know, their, their, their travel interests, their, their, you know, laptop interests, you know, all this other stuff. And, you know, the worst part about that is then some, some of that stuff starts to make it to where like, it's hard to even find what, you know, for, for, for all of, you know, third-party cookies, you know, fault, sometimes you can at least go like, you know, the provider has to give you some sort of lookup usually, or say like, okay, well, what do you know about me? But, you know, this, this, this can be a
set the cookies that you want to, um, you know, there's, there are systems out there that, that help, that helps her reconnect that and say like, oh, okay, actually I thought this was somebody new, but I took this, this, and this, and I pulled all this in and it's like, okay, now I've got, and it's like, now I've got, you know, their, their, their travel interests, their, their, you know, laptop interests, you know, all this other stuff. And, you know, the worst part about that is then some, some of that stuff starts to make it to where like, it's hard to even find what, you know, for, for, for all of, you know, third-party cookies, you know, fault, sometimes you can at least go like, you know, the provider has to give you some sort of lookup usually, or say like, okay, well, what do you know about me? But, you know, this, this, this can be a|||set the cookies that you want to, um, you know, there's, there are systems out there that, that help, that helps her reconnect that and say like, oh, okay, actually I thought this was somebody new, but I took this, this, and this, and I pulled all this in and it's like, okay, now I've got, and it's like, now I've got, you://their, their, their travel interests, their, their, you://laptop interests, you://all this other stuff. And, you://the worst part about that is then some, some of that stuff starts to make it to where like, it's hard to even find what, you://for, for, for all of, you://third-party cookies, you://fault, sometimes you can at least go like, you://the provider has to give you some sort of lookup usually, or say like, okay, well, what do you know about me? But, you://this, this, this can be a
lot, you know, a lot harder to see and a lot more hidden. And, and so, you know, and really, it gets to the point of like, well, look, what do we want to keep building? Do we want to keep having this like arms race with, you know, ad tech providers and browser makers where we're just constantly, you know, upping the game of, you know, measures and countermeasures? Or do we want to like start over, you know, build something interesting from scratch that, you know, meets the privacy requirements, meets the user requirements, rewards them as part of it, you know, for their attention and gets the advertisers
lot, you know, a lot harder to see and a lot more hidden. And, and so, you know, and really, it gets to the point of like, well, look, what do we want to keep building? Do we want to keep having this like arms race with, you know, ad tech providers and browser makers where we're just constantly, you know, upping the game of, you know, measures and countermeasures? Or do we want to like start over, you know, build something interesting from scratch that, you know, meets the privacy requirements, meets the user requirements, rewards them as part of it, you know, for their attention and gets the advertisers|||lot, you know, a lot harder to see and a lot more hidden. And, and so, you://and really, it gets to the point of like, well, look, what do we want to keep building? Do we want to keep having this like arms race with, you://ad tech providers and browser makers where we're just constantly, you://upping the game of, you://measures and countermeasures? Or do we want to like start over, you://build something interesting from scratch that, you://meets the privacy requirements, meets the user requirements, rewards them as part of it, you://for their attention and gets the advertisers
the outcome that they want and then makes it so those users can go and, you know, contribute those earnings back to their favorite creators, like keep the web running. Like, and that seems, you know, that's the alternative that,
the outcome that they want and then makes it so those users can go and, you know, contribute those earnings back to their favorite creators, like keep the web running. Like, and that seems, you know, that's the alternative that,|||the outcome that they want and then makes it so those users can go and, you://contribute those earnings back to their favorite creators, like keep the web running. Like, and that seems, you://that's the alternative that,
you know, we put in a lot of effort to and, you know, that's what we think is going to be important in the future. Yeah, that makes sense. I love the the way that that Brave works on this sort of spectrum where on one end of the spectrum, you know, you can donate some of your, you know, some of your some of your mind and some of your time to to look at some other opportunities. And then you will actually get some of those attention tokens. And then the website that you're on will get some of those attention tokens. And that supports the content creators that are producing that content. And then alternatively, on the other end of the spectrum, you can actually spend, you can actually, you know, you know, spend, you know, you can, you can get bats, you can get these brave attention tokens, you know, just by spending, spending USD or
你知道，我们付出了很多努力，而且，你知道，这就是我们认为未来很重要的事情。是的，这说得通。我非常喜欢 Brave 这种运作模式，它的光谱一端是，你可以捐出你的一部分，你知道的，你的一部分思想和一部分时间去浏览一些其他的机会。然后你实际上会得到其中一些注意力代币。接着，你所在的网站也会得到一些注意力代币。这就支持了创作这些内容的创作者。然后，在光谱的另一端，你实际上可以花，你实际上可以，你知道，你知道，花，你知道，你可以，你可以获得 BAT，你可以获得这些 Brave 注意力代币，你知道，只需花费，花费美元或者
whatever your local currency is, you can get these tokens, and then you can give them directly to these content creators, these websites, and you don't even have to manually manage all of that or subscribe to a paywall and do all of that. You just set up the Brave wall at once for the entire internet. And Brave will also handle, you know, it has some different policies of how you want to distribute that. You could do it, you know, manually, but they also have some automatic policies. And so that whole thing, I think, is a much more elegant way of doing things. Yeah. And you did a great job describing it, right? Because when you sign up for these brave rewards, and if you're seeing these privacy preserving ads, you'll get your payout at the end of the month. And then yeah, all the way,
无论你当地的货币是什么，你都可以获得这些代币，然后你可以直接把它们给这些内容创作者、这些网站，你甚至不需要手动管理所有这一切，或者去订阅付费墙再做那些繁琐的事情。你只需要为整个互联网一次性设置好 Brave 的墙。而且 Brave 还会处理，你知道的，它有一些不同的策略来决定你希望如何分发这些代币。你可以，你知道，手动进行，但他们也有一些自动的策略。所以整个事情，我认为，是一种优雅得多的做事方式。是的。而且你描述得太棒了，对吧？因为当你注册这些 Brave 奖励时，如果你看到了这些保护隐私的广告，你会在月底收到你的收益。然后，是的，一路下来，
you can even say like, oh, look, I love this article. I love this tweet. And you can just go give somebody a bat. Like, oh, great. Great work. Keep up the good work. Or like you're saying, say, okay, look, of what I've earned and taken in, I want you to contribute X amount of bat to the sites that I love. Or you can say, look, I don't want to do any of this stuff entirely, ads in whatever form annoys me, but I do want to support my favorite creators. Great. I'm going to put some bat into the system. I'm going to send it to my favorite creators and support them that way. Right. And we, you know, we want to make sure that, that, you know, there's, there's room for all those different ways of doing
你甚至可以这样说，哦，看，我喜欢这篇文章。我喜欢这条推文。然后你就可以直接给某人一些 BAT。就像，哦，太棒了。干得好。继续保持。或者像你说的，说，好吧，看，在我赚取和收到的代币中，我希望你将一定数量的 BAT 贡献给我喜欢的网站。或者你可以说，看，我根本不想做这些事情，任何形式的广告都会惹恼我，但我确实想支持我最喜欢的创作者。太好了。我要把一些 BAT 放进系统里。我要把它发给我最喜欢的创作者，用这种方式支持他们。对的。而且我们，你知道的，我们希望确保，那，你知道的，有，有空间容纳所有这些不同的方式
it. Cool. Yeah. We've had a couple of, over the years, we've had a couple of cryptocurrency type folks. But I don't think we've really, you know, had a deep dive into Ethereum and these kinds of things. And so maybe just at a high level, what is BAT and how do people get it? Can people turn it into their local fiat currency? How does that whole thing work? Yeah, absolutely. So right, BAT is called like an ERC-20 token, you know, on this Ethereum network. And that really just describes a set of sort of standard interfaces for this token that like, you know, it works in a lot of the ways you expected. You can trade it around, send it, you know, all that other stuff. But yeah, there are many different places. Now you can go to different, you know, these different providers on the web, go say like,
来做这件事。酷。是的。多年来，我们有过几个，有过几个加密货币类型的人。但我认为我们并没有真正，你知道的，深入探讨过以太坊以及这类事情。所以也许只是从宏观层面来看，什么是 BAT，人们是如何获得它的？人们能把它变成当地的法定货币吗？整个过程是如何运作的？是的，完全可以。所以，对吧，BAT 被称为一种 ERC-20 代币，你知道的，在以太坊网络上。这其实只是描述了一组针对这个代币的标准接口，就像，你知道的，它在很多方面都如你所预期的那样运作。你可以交易它、发送它，你知道，所有这些其他东西。但，是的，有很多不同的地方。现在你可以去不同的，你知道的，网络上的这些不同的提供商那里，去说，
great, you know, I want to buy 100 bat. I, you know, I'm really interested in this. And then it, you know, it's compatible with our ecosystem. And, you know, so and look, I will again caveat by saying, you know, it's so, and, and, and, and look, I will again, caveat by saying, you know, I, I never came into too brave as, as the crypto expert and, and I still, still would not claim to be, but, you know, I feel confident, you know, more than me, Patrick actually is a crypto. I don't know if he's a secret crypto guru, but he just, in general seems to know more than I do. But, but no, I mean,
太棒了，你知道，我想买 100 个 BAT。我，你知道，我对这个真的很感兴趣。然后它，你知道，它与我们的生态系统兼容。而且，你知道，所以，看，我再次打个预防针说，你知道，它是如此，而且，而且，而且，看，我再次打个预防针说，你知道，我，我加入 Brave 时从来都不是作为一个加密货币专家，而且，我仍然，仍然不会自称是，但是，你知道，我觉得很有信心，你知道，比我懂得多得多，帕特里克其实才是个加密货币。我不知道他是不是一个秘密的加密货币大师，但他只是，总的来说，似乎比我知道得更多。但是，但是不，我是说，
you've explained it really well. Definitely. Yeah. I'm starting to paint a bigger, better picture here. Yeah. I mean, and what makes it, you know, really exciting, right. It's like, look, the way this came about and, and I think what, what's so cool about, you know, coins like this, you know, they, they have these, like these ICOs, these initial coin offerings and, and Brave was no, no different, you know, it's like, okay, well look look, we're minting all these, you know, these new coins and, you know, people can and they did, you know, support the future of Brave, you know. You know, when the Brave team sort of put, you know, put that out there and said, look, here's they put out the white paper. They said, here's what we really want to do. Here's how we want to, you know, reshape the
你解释得真的很好。绝对是的。我开始在这里描绘一幅更大、更好的图景了。是的。我是说，是什么让它，你知道，真的令人兴奋，对吧？就像，看，这件事是怎么来的，而且，我认为，像这样币，最酷的地方在于，你知道，它们，它们有这些，就像这些 ICO，这些首次代币发行，而且，Brave 也不例外，你知道，就像，好吧，看，看，我们正在铸造所有这些，你知道的，这些新币，而且，你知道，人们可以，而且他们也确实这样做了，你知道，支持 Brave 的未来，你知道。你知道，当 Brave 团队某种程度上把，你知道，把那个摆出来并说，看，这里是，他们发布了白纸黑字。他们说，这才是我们真正想做的。这就是我们想要如何重塑
economics of the internet. We think this is the right way to do it. You know, here's the team that we're forming and building to, to do just that. And people went in and they said, okay, well, like, I think there's value, you know, there's value in this future. I want to buy some of this token. And it's such a cool grassroots way of supporting projects that you love. And of course, I will not name names, but there are also plenty of coin offerings out there. I've heard about some sketchy ICOs. But this is, I mean, I think from the beginning, it was clear that this is a real business, a real product. Some of the ICOs are just, it was in January, I think we paid out something like
互联网的经济学。我们认为这是正确的做法。你知道，这是我们正在组建和建立的团队，来做这件事。然后人们进来了，他们说，好吧，像，我认为有价值，你知道，这个未来是有价值的。我想买一些这种代币。这是一种非常酷的、基层的方式来支持你所爱的人的项目。当然，我不会点名，但外面也有很多代币发行。我听说过一些不靠谱的 ICO。但这个，我是说，我认为从一开始就很清楚，这是一个真正的企业，一个真正的产品。有些 ICO 只是，我想在 1 月份，我们以 BAT 的形式向大约
eight and a half million Brave users in the form of BAT. And so it's, what I love about Brave, and there are again, a lot of companies, like you're saying out there that are, sort of consider themselves in the crypto space and work with it. And we are very much not just like crypto for crypto's sake. It's like, look, this is obviously like Brave super appeals, crypto savvy users. There are, you know, I have been lucky to work with, you know, some of the most like brilliant crypto people that, that, you know, I've ever, ever met, you know you know, here, here at Brave and people who like really understand these things inside and out. But more than anything, it's like, look, we know that this is an, an important tool to a,
八百五十万 Brave 用户发放了奖励。所以，我喜欢 Brave 的一点是，当然也有很多公司，就像你说的，在外面，那些，某种程度上认为自己处于加密货币领域并与之合作。而我们绝不仅仅是“为了加密货币而加密货币”。就像，看，这显然就像 Brave 极大地吸引了精通加密货币的用户。有，你知道，我有幸与，你知道的，一些最像，才华横溢的加密货币人才合作，这些人才，你知道，我从来没有，从来没有遇到过的，你知道，你懂的，在这里，在 Brave，还有那些真正对这些事情有透彻理解的人。但最重要的是，就像，看，我们知道这是一个，一个重要的工具，通往一个
you know, to a vibrant future right because you know like and look and there's some systems that you kind of need to to bridge that you know the the the sort of blockchains aren't always ready and there's still like a ton of development and like every year it's it's different yeah actually kind of a question there is is why uh and this is maybe a dumb question but why are there different coins so like like specifically with Brave, like why not use Ethereum or Bitcoin or one of these things? Like what's the advantage in making a new form of currency? Yeah, absolutely. And look, the early versions of, you know, Brave that did this, you know, did this with Bitcoin, right?
你知道，充满活力的未来，对吧？因为你知道，像，看，而且有些系统你某种程度上需要去连接，你知道，区块链并不总是准备就绪的，而且仍然有大量的开发工作，并且每年都在变化。是的，其实这里有个问题，为什么呃，这可能是一个愚蠢的问题，但为什么会有不同的币？比如，特别是在 Brave 上，为什么不使用以太坊或比特币或其他这些东西呢？制造一种新形式的货币有什么好处？是的，绝对的。并且你看，你知道，早期版本的 Brave 确实做过，你知道，用比特币做过这个，对吧？
Because the, you know, the ICO hadn't happened yet. And then that was definitely before my time. But, you know, the thing is, like, you know, what gives rise to like so many of these different coins is that, like, you know, one, Ethereum is like very cool and interesting because, you know, of things like they call, you know, smart contracts, right? Where it's like on the blockchain, you can sort of put code on the blockchain that will like, that will execute you could do all these, you know, really interesting things with it. And I think the Brave team, you know, at the time knew that, like, look, have having, you know, sort of your own token, one gave you this, like, you know, a lot of these
因为，你知道，ICO 还没有发生。那绝对是在我加入之前。但是，你知道，事情是这样的，就像，你知道，是什么催生了这么多不同的币呢？因为，你知道，第一，以太坊非常酷且有趣，因为，你知道的，他们称之为，你知道，智能合约之类的东西，对吧？就像在区块链上，你可以把代码放在区块链上，它会，它会执行，你可以用它做所有这些，你知道，非常有趣的事情。而且我认为 Brave 团队，你知道，当时就知道，就像，看，拥有，你知道，某种程度上属于你自己的代币，一方面给了你这个，你知道，很多
really interesting things that you could start to do in the future, like you start to make these, you know, these sort of really, you know, smart things around it that are imposed, you know, by the blockchain, and that future is like really appealing. And two, you know, a really important part of the ICO is this, you know, the team allocated a bunch of tokens for what they called the user growth pool, right? And so the idea was like, hey, look, we are going to use, we're allocating a certain amount of this to help bootstrap these, you know, this system, right? And make it, you know, interesting for users and creators and like, you know to to get that going and and you know so those kinds of things i think tend to be like really you know really important for projects like
你将来可以开始做的非常有趣的事情，比如你开始围绕它制作这些，你知道的，这些某种程度上非常，你知道，由区块链强加的智能事情，而那个未来真的是非常吸引人的。第二，你知道，ICO 的一个非常重要的部分是这个，你知道，团队分配了一大批代币用于他们所谓的“用户增长池”，对吧？所以这个想法是，嘿，看，我们要使用，我们分配了一定数量的代币来帮助启动这些，你知道，这个系统，对吧？并使它，你知道，对用户和创作者来说很有趣，并且，你知道，让它运转起来，并且，你知道，所以这些事情，我认为往往是，真的，你知道，对像
this to help get off the ground you know oh that makes sense that makes sense so by creating sort of a separate token you're creating um like a unique like a like a siloed risk profile so basically you could give a bunch of Brave tokens to folks, and then they have an incentive now to keep the Brave ecosystem healthy versus if you just gave Ethereum to random people, then that's just money in a well, and who knows what would really have happened. Yeah. And like we said, we can do stuff, you know, some of our systems help, you know, handle the parts that are still maturing, you know, on Web3. And so for instance, like when you want to send, you'll hear people in like crypto complain about, you know, gas fees. And really, it's just like, these like high transaction costs.
这样的项目来说非常重要，以帮助它们起步，你知道。哦，这说得通，这说得通。所以通过创造一种相对独立的代币，你实际上是在创造一个独特的、孤立的风险配置文件，基本上你可以把一堆 Brave 代币给人们，然后他们现在就有动力去保持 Brave 生态系统的健康，而不是如果你只是把以太坊给随机的人，那就像把钱扔进水井里，谁知道最后会发生什么呢。是的。而且就像我们说的，我们可以做一些事情，你知道，我们的一些系统有助于，你知道，处理 Web3 上仍然在走向成熟的部分。所以例如，当你想要发送时，你会听到加密货币领域的人抱怨，你知道，gas 费用。实际上，这只是像，这些很高的交易成本。
And, you know, for instance, a lot of what Brave has, you know, tried to work on. So it's, you know, it's like, if you think about trying to contribute a creator, right, like to a creator, one of the sort of obvious and more straightforward things that people did for a while was like, hey, look, great, I'm gonna put my ETH address on here. And whenever you'd like, you can, you can send me, you know, send me like, like do it or, or, or, you know, uh, Bitcoin. And, you know, it's like, and so what, you know, Ethereum fees, like transaction fees have been like really high. So it's like, okay, you know, if I have to pay 10 or $15 to send somebody a dollar that doesn't work very well, right. And so a lot of the gap, you know, that Brave helped to bridge was saying like, okay,
而且，你知道，例如，Brave 一直在努力工作的一大方向。所以，它是，你知道的，如果你考虑尝试向创作者贡献，对吧，比如向一个创作者，人们一段时间以来做过的显而易见且更直接的事情之一就是，嘿，看，太好了，我要把我的以太坊地址放在这里。每当你想的时候，你可以，你可以发给我，你知道，发给我，你知道，就像，或者，或者，你知道，呃，比特币。而且，你知道，所以，你知道，以太坊费用，比如交易费用一直非常高。所以这就变成，好吧，你知道，如果我必须支付 10 美元或 15 美元来给某人发送一美元，这根本行不通，对吧。所以 Brave 帮助弥合的很大一部分差距就是说，好吧，
look, you can actually, you know, you can actually give, you know, sort of these, you know, you can contribute to your favorite creators with these tokens, our systems will actually help keep, you know, keep the fees to basically, you know, keep the fees minimal, make it anonymous in the way you contribute to it, right? So we actually don't know that it's coming from, you know, okay, well, it's we've, you know, we've tracked, you know, we've tracked the contributions of this Ethereum address. So we know that, you know, the same user has done this, right? Our system sort of helped to keep those votes and contributions anonymous and reduce the fees on things. And then ultimately, then they will later in aggregate get, what they say, settled on chain, actually sent to a crypto address to try to keep this practical. So now, in the Brave system, you can go and you can say, great know, sent to, you know, to a crypto address, like to try to, you know, to try to keep this practical. So now like in the brave system, right, you can go and you can
看，你实际上可以，你知道，你实际上可以给，你知道，某种程度上这些，你可以用这些代币向你最喜欢的创作者贡献，我们的系统实际上会帮助保持，你知道，把费用保持在，基本上，你知道，把费用降到最低，使你贡献的方式保持匿名，对吧？所以我们实际上并不知道它是来自，你知道，好吧，它，我们已经，你知道，我们追踪了，我们追踪了某个以太坊地址的贡献。所以我们知道，你知道，是同一个用户做了这件事，对吧？我们的系统某种程度上帮助保持了这些投票和贡献的匿名性，并降低了各种费用的成本。然后最终，它们随后会在聚合层面上进行，他们所说的，链上结算，实际上发送到一个加密钱包地址，以尽量保持其实用性。所以现在，在 Brave 系统中，你可以去说，太好了，你知道，发送到一个加密钱包地址，就像试着，你知道，试着让这保持实用。所以现在就像在 Brave 系统中一样，你可以去
say, great, I want to send, I love this tweet. Here's a dollar. And it's like this easy, low friction way. Or, you know, I love this article. Like I really want to support this, this creator, like great, the super low friction way. Like, Hey, I earned, you know, five or six bucks in bat last time. You know, this was good earned, you know, five or six bucks in bat last time, you know, this was good reporting, you know, here's, here's, here's a dollar. And it's funny that that, you know, interestingly enough, you know, if you're, if you're a creator with a sort of ads driven site, you know, like, getting a direct and low friction contribution of a dollar, you know, can be, you know, in aggregate big, because,
说，太好了，我想发送，我喜欢这条推文。这是一美元。就像这种简单、低摩擦的方式。或者，你知道，我喜欢这篇文章。就像我真的想支持这个创作者，太好了，这种超级低摩擦的方式。就像，嘿，我上次在 BAT 中赚了五六块钱。你知道，这是好东西，赚了，你知道，上次在 BAT 中赚了五六块钱，你知道，这是很好的报道，你知道，给你，给你，给你一美元。很有趣的是，你知道，有趣的是，如果你是一个拥有广告驱动型网站的创作者，你知道，获得一美元的直接且低摩擦的贡献，你知道，在聚合后可能会很大，因为，
you know, sometimes those, you know, find you've loaded an article and a typical, you know, they call it like programmatic impression on a, you know, on like some publisher site, maybe a dollar, you know, CPM, and that that means like $1 per 1000 of them. So it's like, you know, CPM. And that, that means like a dollar per thousand of them. So it's like, you know, versus like, oh, okay, well, hey, I, I saw ads and I contributed to, you know, to your page, right? Like, or, you know, like that, that's the good idea. Like that might only be, you know, 0.3 cents, you know, whereas if, you know, a few interested people, you know, want to make contributions and have a good low friction way to do it, like, you know, want to make contributions and have a good low friction way to do it, like, you know, that can be worth actually like quite a few ads, you know, seen on a site. Yeah. Yeah. That makes sense. Totally makes sense. I think, plus, you know, it allows
你知道，有时那些，你知道，发现你加载了一篇文章，而在一个典型的，你知道的，他们称之为程序化展示广告的网站上，在某个发布商网站上，可能是一美元的，你知道，CPM，而这意味着，你知道，每千次展示一美元。所以就像，你知道，CPM。而这意味着，你知道，每千次展示一美元。所以就像，你知道，相比于，哦，好吧，嘿，我，我看到了广告并且我为，你知道，你的页面做出了贡献，对吧？就像，或者，你知道，就像，那是个好主意。那可能只有，你知道，0.3 美分，然而，如果，你知道，少数感兴趣的人，你知道，想要做出贡献并且有一种很好的低摩擦方式来做到这一点，就像，你知道，想要做出贡献并且有一种很好的低摩擦方式来做到这一点，就像，你知道，这实际上可能相当于在网站上看到相当多的广告。是的。是的。这说得通。完全说得通。我想，另外，你知道，它允许
people to, you know, to really tangibly clearly see, you know, how much value they are creating. I think that, I mean, anything with donations, you know, there's a ton of psychology around donations and how that all works. But, but I mean, clearly, there's a correlation between how many donations you're going to get and the value that you're providing. And so you can, you can measure that. And you can ultimately, you know, most people who are producing content, they are ultimately, they're trying to provide the best possible service. And so this gives them a nice measuring stick. That's right. Yeah, absolutely. Very cool. So, you know, one of the things that, that, you know know i really liked uh back in i guess 2009 or something when google started really pushing chrome and and you know logging into chrome and you're having your sort of identity
人们，你知道，能够真正有形地、清楚地看到，你知道，他们正在创造多少价值。我认为，我是说，任何涉及捐赠的事情，你知道，捐赠周围有很多心理学，以及这一切是如何运作的。但是，但是我的意思是，显然，你将获得的捐赠数量与你所提供的价值之间存在相关性。所以你可以，你可以衡量这一点。并且你最终可以，你知道，大多数制作内容的人，他们最终都在努力提供最好的服务。所以这为他们提供了一个很好的衡量标准。没错。是的，绝对的。太酷了。所以，你知道，其中一件事情，就是，你知道，我真的很喜欢，呃，早在 2009 年左右或其他时候，当谷歌开始真正大力推行 Chrome 时，并且，你知道，登录 Chrome，然后你拥有某种身份
you know attached to the browser was just the fact that like you know your bookmarks kind of went everywhere you did your history kind of went everywhere and so is that kind of stuff possible and brave i actually don't don't honestly don't know the answer to this question but but is there kind of went everywhere. And so is that kind of stuff possible in Brave? I actually honestly don't know the answer to this question, but is there a way to sort of sync your bookmarks and your history and all of that, given that there really is no, you're not logging in when you install Brave? Jason, I'm so glad that you asked. I mean, if it's true, I need to set it up because currently it's not synchronized. I feel like it gave me a real softball here. So that's great.
绑定到浏览器上，仅仅是因为，你知道，你的书签随你到处走，你的历史记录也随你到处走，那么这种事情在 Brave 中可能吗？我其实不，老实说不知道这个问题的答案，但是是否有，随你到处走。所以，这种事情在 Brave 中可能吗？我其实老实说到现在都不知道这个问题的答案，但是有没有一种方法可以同步你的书签、历史记录和所有这些，考虑到实际上并没有，当你安装 Brave 时你并没有登录？杰森，我太高兴你问这个了。我是说，如果这是真的，我需要去设置一下，因为目前它还没有同步。我觉得你在这里抛给我一个非常轻松的球。所以这太棒了。
I thought the answer was going to be no. So I thought that. One of the things that my team works on is BraveSync. Or, you know, yeah. So it's interesting. You know, Brave is based on Chromium, which for, you know, for, for, for anybody that doesn't know, like that's, that's the same sort of open source core that is in, you know, Google Chrome that like, you know, everybody's familiar with, right?
我以为答案会是否定的。所以我之前是这么想的。我团队负责的事情之一就是 Brave Sync。或者，你知道，是的。所以这很有趣。你知道，Brave 是基于 Chromium 的，对于，你知道，对于，对于任何不知道的人来说，这就是，那和谷歌 Chrome 中使用的开源核心是同一个东西，你知道，每个人都很熟悉，对吧？
Yeah. Actually, do you know anything? I'm really curious about the history of that. Like, like, like, do you know, do you or Brandon or other folks in your circles know really how Chrome came about to be an open source thing and what went on there? Oh, that's a good question. No, I'm sure they would know the history of it. I don't, but it's sort of been, been, you know, been that way as long as I can remember. And, you know, and it's, and it's good, because it does give, you know, now projects like ours, of course, can sort of say, like, okay, look, we're taking the we're taking the core of that, but we want to bring it in this direction, you know, and I, and look, I think it's paid off for them too, right? Like, our team, you know, quote quote unquote, upstream stuff all the time where we say like, Oh, actually we found this, found this problem in, you know, core chromium, like, and, you know,
是的。实际上，你知道任何关于它的历史吗？我真的很好奇。比如，比如，你或者布兰登或者你圈子里的其他人真的知道 Chrome 是怎么变成一个开源项目的吗，那里到底发生了什么？哦，是个好问题。不，我确信他们会知道它的历史。我不知道，但它基本上一直是，你知道的，自我记事起就是这样的。而且，你知道，而且这很好，因为它确实赋予了，你知道，现在像我们这样的项目，当然可以某种程度上说，好吧，看，我们正在采用它的核心，但我们想把它带往这个方向，你知道，而且，看，我认为这对他们来说也得到了回报，对吧？就像，我们的团队，你知道，引用，引用，引用，不断地向上游贡献代码，我们说，哦，其实我们在核心 Chromium 中发现了这个，发现了这个问题，像，而且，你知道，
they pull in our, our pull request and, you know, everybody, everybody benefits. Right. And so, but, but yeah, so it's for, for at least the last, you know, three years it's based on, yeah. Chromium I think a little bit before that, like, it used to be based on this, this fork of Electron, you know, like, now based on Chromium. And, and, and, of course, it's like, if you base on Chromium, the good part is like, a bunch of stuff is sort of done there for you. And there's, you know, you solve, you can solve these compatibility issues, but still get a lot of the protections that you want. But interestingly enough, like, so, you know, Google has a sync, you can turn on sync,
他们拉取我们的合并请求，然后，每个人，每个人都受益。对吧。所以，但是，但是是的，所以至少在过去的，你知道，三年里，它是基于，是的，Chromium。我想在此之前的一段时间里，它曾经基于，这个，Electron 的分支，你知道，就像，现在基于 Chromium。而且，而且，当然，就像，如果你基于 Chromium，好的部分是，一堆东西在里面已经为你做好了。并且有，你知道的，你可以解决这些兼容性问题，但仍然获得你想要的许多保护。但有趣的是，像，所以，谷歌有一个同步功能，你可以开启同步，
sync your bookmarks and all that other stuff, right? And because the client side code, like the stuff that talks to the server is open source, right? That's, We can use that too. But the server side of Google Sync is not open source. And so we had had this legacy sort of sync system actually before that, that we kind of carried through. And after the switch to Chromium, we said, okay, well, look, if, you know, we want to make this, we want to give everybody the stuff that they're used to, exactly like you're saying, it's like, you know, we want a way to give people, you know, like great bookmarks sync and, you know, password sync and, you know, sync their tabs and all that other stuff. You know, how do we do that? Like, how do we do that in the lightest way possible? And so what we did in the end was we sort of, you know, the team here, you know, a lot of the browser engineers kind of dug into it and sort of made a, you know, wire compatible, you know,
同步你的书签和所有其他东西，对吧？并且因为客户端代码，就像与服务器对话的东西是开源的，对吧？那是，我们也可以使用它。但是 Google Sync 的服务端并不是开源的。所以我们实际上在之前就有一个传统的同步系统，我们一直沿用到现在。在切换到 Chromium 之后，我们说，好吧，看，如果，你知道，我们想把它做好，我们想给每个人他们习惯的东西，就像你刚说的，就像，你知道，我们想要一种方法给人们，你知道，比如出色的书签同步和，你知道，密码同步，以及，你知道，同步他们的标签页和所有其他东西。我们该怎么做？就像，我们如何在尽可能轻量级的方式下做到这一点？所以我们最终做的是，我们某种程度上，你知道，这里的团队，你知道，许多浏览器工程师对此进行了深入研究，并制作了一个，你知道，连线兼容的，你知道，
sync protocol that we could then, you know, open source and like run on our servers. And a key difference is that it's, it's kind of a little known mode, but Chrome actually has a locally encrypted by default mode for, for your sync. And so that's actually what, what we are saying, but it's, it's not a default. It's like, it's like a, you know, obscure setting. But in contrast, we said, okay, like ours is going to be locally encrypted by default. So you get this system that's kind of like the best of both worlds, right? Like you sign up to your, you say like, okay, I want to enable BraveSync. You get this, you know, key that, you know, it's one of those, you know, sets of words that, you know, makes actually a local encryption key. All that bookmark data,
同步协议，然后我们可以，你知道，将其开源并在我们的服务器上运行。一个关键的区别是，它，它是一个鲜为人知的模式，但其实 Chrome 默认有一个本地加密的模式用于你的同步。所以这实际上就是，我们正在做的，但它不是默认的。它就像是一个，你知道，晦涩的设置。但相比之下，我们说，好吧，我们的将默认进行本地加密。所以你得到了一个有点像两全其美的系统，对吧？就像你注册你的，你说，好吧，我想要启用 Brave Sync。你得到了这个，你知道的，密钥，你知道，它是那种，你知道，由一串单词组成的，你知道的，实际上会生成一个本地加密密钥。所有书签数据，
everything you choose to sync is locally encrypted with that key. We do not, you know, Brave never gets that key. You know, we do not have it anything like that you locally encrypt your stuff like on your on your computer and then you you send it up to to the brave servers like encrypted so um oh it's similar to like a proton mail or something where where it's uh you it's end-to-end encryption so you have the encryption on your phone and then it goes to so you are actually holding you know the people's bookmarks but just encrypted somewhere on a on a server now when someone comes in with their desktop um but then i guess like what's the user id then because there's no account right yeah so so it it's um it's it's sort of very you of very reminiscent of crypto because your quote unquote ID is just the public key of this and you encrypt stuff with the private key of this.
你选择同步的一切都用该密钥进行本地加密。我们不会，你知道，Brave 永远不会得到那个密钥。你知道，我们没有任何类似的东西，你在你的电脑上对你的东西进行本地加密，然后你把它发送到 Brave 服务器上，是加密的，所以……哦，这类似于 ProtonMail 之类的东西，它是端到端加密的，所以你在手机上进行加密，然后它发往……所以现在实际上是由你来保存（用户的书签），只不过是作为加密数据存放在某个服务器上，对吧？那么当某人用他们的桌面端访问时，嗯，那用户 ID 是什么呢，因为这里没有账号对吧？是的，所以它是，它是，它有点，非常让人联想到加密货币，因为你所谓的 ID 只是它的公钥，然后你用它的私钥来加密东西。
Oh, I see. So you have some database where given a public key, here's all of your data. And so I see. So anybody can get jimmy's data it's just encrypted because they can't actually decrypt it no correction there like you actually have to sign and prove that you own the private key to even request it right and so it's like so it's still oh i see it's still protected it's still you know like you know nobody with just your public like even though you don't really share your public key with anybody, nobody with just your public key could, could go get your data.
哦，我明白了。所以你有一个数据库，给定一个公钥，这里就是你的所有数据。所以，我明白了。所以任何人都可以获取吉米的数据，它只是被加密了，因为他们实际上无法解密它？不对，纠正一下，你实际上必须进行签名并证明你拥有私钥才能请求它，对吧？所以它就像，所以它依然，哦，我明白了，它依然受到保护，它依然，你知道，像，你知道，没有人仅仅通过你的公钥——即使你并没有真正和任何人分享你的公钥——没有人仅凭你的公钥就能去获取你的数据。
Like it's your request still has to be signed with your private key. And then we know that you're authorized to do it. You never share your private key with us. And then only, only you using your private key can decrypt this, you know? So, so right. You never receive this private key with us. And then only, only you using your private key can decrypt this, you know? So, so right. We've never received this private key and you know, so right. Only you can request it. And even if somehow somebody did get access to that data, they would have, it would be useless to them because they would not have your private key and it would just be encrypted blobs. Got it. Yeah. One of these uh we should get someone on the show
就像你的请求仍然必须用你的私钥进行签名。然后我们才知道你是被授权这样做的。你从未与我们分享你的私钥。然后只有，只有你使用你的私钥才能解密这个，你知道吗？所以，所以，对吧？我们从来没有收到过这个私钥，然后，你知道，所以，只有你能请求它。即使不知怎么有人真的获取了那些数据，对他们来说也是毫无用处的，因为他们没有你的私钥，那只是一堆加密的二进制数据。明白了。是的。这其中的一个，我们应该请一个懂的人来节目里，因为你知道，那个签名部分我还是不太理解，呃，像我理解你怎么朝一个方向走，但我没有，但，但是，是的，我相信这是可能的，我只是不知道怎么做，像你怎么能，所以如果你有私钥和公钥，别人怎么能知道你就是你呢？我想，我想也许你加密了，哦，帕特里克，也许你想加入进来？你似乎对加密了解得多得多。
who knows because you know that that the signing part i still don't quite understand uh um like i understand how you can go in one direction but i didn't but but yeah i'm sure it's possible i just don't know how uh like how you can uh so if you have if you have the private and public key how how can someone else know that you're you um i guess i guess maybe you encrypt oh patrick uh maybe you want to jump in you seem to know a lot more crypto that's right so i mean i think the difference is like most people think in terms of symmetric key cryptography and in symmetric key the same key will encode something and decode something right so the the key with public key cryptography oh i said key twice is you have one asymmetric so if somebody uses the public key the one you share then only the private key will undo
没错。所以我的意思是，区别在于大多数人是以对称密钥密码学的思维来思考的，在对称密钥中，相同的密钥可以加密某物也可以解密某物，对吧？所以公钥密码学的关键——哦，我说了两次“密钥”——是你拥有一个非对称的，所以如果某人使用公钥——你分享的那把公钥——那么只有私钥才能撤销那次加密。但好消息是，由于它的设计方式，拿一条消息来说，比如就说是你的名字，杰森，然后你用你的私钥对它进行签名。如果我拿到你的公钥并把它应用到那条消息上，然后我解密得到了“杰森”，那么我就知道只有杰森才能做出“杰森”这个动作，前提是我拥有的公钥确实是杰森的公钥。而知道谁的公钥是谁则是另一个完全不同的课题，比如你如何建立信任根来知道公钥属于这个人？但是如果你有，你仍然信任一个服务器，服务器会向你发送一个挑战（Challenge），对吧？挑战就是当前的时间戳加上某个随机数之类的东西，然后你需要把你的私钥放入算法中来加密该信息。如果有人拦截了它，无论怎样他们都无法用它做什么。它被发送到服务器，服务器利用它对你的公钥的认知进行解码，并确保你就是签署了那个挑战、那段信息的人，除了你没有别人能做到。因为如果他们做到了，他们就得拥有你的私钥，那样的话你就已经完蛋了。所以，通过这种方式，你可以某种程度上执行这个，你可以证明你是谁，并且你通过用私钥做只有私钥才能做的事来证明你是谁。
that encryption but the nice thing is that because of how it's designed, taking a message, so just say it's your name, Jason, and you use your private key to sign it. If I take your public key and apply it to that, and I get back out Jason, then I know only Jason could have done Jason if the public key I have is jason's public key which knowing whose key it is is a whole separate topic and like how do you have a
（无对应原文，跳过）
root of trust for knowing that the public key is the person but if you have you're still trusting a server to say that like the server is going to send you a challenge right the challenge is the current time stamp plus some random number or whatever and then you need to put your private key into the algorithm to encrypt that that information if someone intercepted it if whatever they can't do anything with it it goes up to the server the server takes its knowledge of your public key and decodes it and make sure that you are the one who signed that challenge that bit of information and no one else could have done it because if they did they had your private key and you're already screwed so uh that way that you can sort of perform this this uh you can prove who you are
and you prove who you are by doing something with your private key that only the private key could have done yeah that makes sense and that way like if if there is a person in the middle who has your public key you know they see that you passed the challenge but that doesn't really you know that's not a security issue i mean yeah so like replay attack or them getting in the middle of you would be a separate issue so they wouldn't send you a clear text of the challenge they would send you their encrypted version of the challenge and that way someone in the middle couldn't intercept it. Oh, right. Okay, cool.
是的，这说得通，这样一来，如果在中间有一个人拥有你的公钥，你知道，他们看到你通过了挑战，但这真的，你知道，这不是一个安全问题。我的意思是，是的，就像重放攻击或者他们在你中间进行窃听会是另一个问题。所以他们不会向你发送挑战的明文，他们会发送他们加密版本的挑战，这样中间人就无法拦截它。哦，对的。好的，酷。
That is awesome. So, okay, so circling back here, so you don't even get, I mean, not that, you know, I mean, the public key is very, or the key in general is very hard to break, but you don't even have to worry about that because you can't get the data
这太棒了。所以，好吧，那么回到这里，所以你甚至连，我的意思是，倒不是说，你知道，我的意思是，公钥非常，或者总的来说密钥非常难破解，但你甚至不必担心这一点，因为你无法获取数据，
to where then you could just, you know, thrash away at it unless you can prove yourself first yeah that's that's right that's right even even if you you know even if you did get access to that data right it would be encrypted you know and only the private key holder would be able to decrypt it and so so uh um got it and so so, okay, that makes sense. So, yeah, that's a really cool service. I think it must be a pretty large database. I mean, I'm just thinking like that's wild.
除非你能先证明你自己，否则你根本无法对它进行蛮力破解。是的，完全正确，完全正确。即使你，你知道，即使你真的获取了那些数据，对吧，它也是被加密的，你知道，只有私钥持有者才能解密它，所以，呃，明白了，所以，好吧，这说得通。所以，是的，这是一个非常酷的服务。我想这一定是一个相当大的数据库。我是说，我只是觉得这太疯狂了。
But I guess, you know, with all the cloud stuff out there, they make it so easy to scale. And look, the good news is now, you know, if you go, our sync server code, it's done in Golang. And, you know, you can see it on our GitHub. It uses DynamoDB for any of you AWS fans. Oh, nice. You know, backend storage, which has been real helpful, real scalable. No, right.
但我想，你知道，有了外面所有的云计算技术，他们让扩展变得如此简单。而且，看，好消息是现在，如果你去的话，我们的同步服务器代码是用 Golang 编写的，你知道的，你可以在我们的 GitHub 上看到它。对于任何 AWS 的粉丝来说，它使用的是 DynamoDB。哦，不错。你知道，作为后端存储，这真的很有帮助，扩展性很好。不，没错。
It's big, but I think our users seem to enjoy it, and that's what matters. Cool. So maybe we'll touch on one last thing, and then I want to talk about brave the company. I want to make sure we leave time for that. But, but one last thing is if you are a content creator, you know, you have, um, you know, jimmy.com and you produce a bunch of blogs and it's really popular and you want to be a part of this and you want to receive support from brave folks, you know, like how do you sort of sign up and get that going? Yes, super simple. Go to creators.brave.com. And, and you can sign up and there's a bunch of, you know, so basically, what you do in that is sort of you prove that you, you know, either own the site or the, you know, the account or whatever it is. But it's interesting, you can sign up with it,
它是很大的，但我想我们的用户似乎很喜欢它，这才是最重要的。酷。所以也许我们最后谈一个话题，然后我想聊聊 Brave 这家公司。我得确保我们留出时间谈那个。但是，但是最后一件事情是，如果你是一个内容创作者，你知道，你拥有，jimmy.com，并且你制作了一堆博客，它非常受欢迎，你想成为其中的一部分，并希望得到 Brave 用户的支持，你知道，你该如何注册并开始呢？是的，超级简单。去 creators.brave.com。然后你可以注册，并且有一堆，你知道，所以基本上，你在其中做的事情就是证明你，你知道，要么拥有这个网站，要么拥有这个账号，无论它是什么。但很有趣的是，你可以用它注册，
you know, for a lot of different platforms, too, right? So yeah, not only can you put your site on there, if you have a, you know, YouTube channel, if you have a Twitter handle, you know, there's, there's a, you know, like, Reddit now, or, you know, even if you are a, you know, prolific Reddit user, like you can, you know, you can let user, you can let people contribute to you when they thought you did a great job. Cool, that makes sense. Yeah, because there's probably a lot of trickery there. There's youtube.com,
你知道，也可以用于许多不同的平台，对吧？所以，是的，你不仅可以把你的网站放在上面，如果你有一个 YouTube 频道，如果你有一个推特账号，你知道，有一个，就像 Reddit 现在，或者，甚至如果你是一个，你知道，高产的 Reddit 用户，你可以，你知道，当人们认为你做得很好时，你可以让用户向你进行贡献。酷，这说得通。是的，因为那里可能有很多恶作剧。有 youtube.com，
but then there's m.youtube.com if you're on mobile. And so by providing an easy way, you kind of handle all that complexity. Yeah, right. I mean, I mean, it's, it can, it gets complex under the hood, you know, the rewards team that works on this, right. You know, we're constantly sort of, you know, working along with, with, you know, things that can break on those sites too, but, you know,
但如果你用手机，还有 m.youtube.com。所以通过提供一种简单的方法，你某种程度上处理了所有这些复杂性。是的，对吧。我是说，我是说，在底层它确实会变得很复杂，你知道，负责这个的奖励团队，你知道，我们一直在某种程度上，你知道，与那些在这些网站上可能会出故障的事情一起工作，但是，你知道，
fixing them back up to make sure that, that, you know, okay, like we, we know a creator, you know, we, we, you know, we know where we should send the bat for sure that that you know okay like we we know a creator you know we you know we know where we should send the bat for this basically you know right right very cool yeah so if you're out there and you uh create content on on on um on the internet i guess i mean pretty much anything is uh you know check this out and uh it's a really good opportunity what about um did you have like a badge or something where people can can put a little badge on their website saying letting other people know that they take the brave token like how does the discoverability part work yeah so so look if you are well one if if you're doing this in brave you'll see that there's a
修复它们以确保，你知道，好吧，我们，我们认识一个创作者，你知道，我们，你知道，我们知道我们应该把 BAT 发到哪里，这绝对是，你知道，好吧，我们，我们认识一个创作者，你知道，我们，你知道，我们知道我们应该把 BAT 发给这个创作者，基本上，你知道，对吧，对吧，非常酷。是的，所以如果你在听，你呃在互联网上创作内容，我想，我是说，几乎任何内容都是，你知道，来看看这个，这真的是一个很好的机会。关于，呃，你们是不是有一个徽章或者什么东西，可以让人们在自己的网站上放一个小徽章，让其他人知道他们接受 Brave 代币？可发现性部分是如何运作的呢？是的，所以看，如果你是，首先如果你在 Brave 中这样做，你会看到有一个
little um a little little bat triangle that will show a checkmark to say, like, oh, you're a verified creator. So it's a little bit part of the Brave experience. And of course, creators who want to proudly, that they love brave. I think, um, I think our, actually our, um, our site, if you go to brave.com, there's a bunch of brand assets there that I think they're, they're able to use. So, uh, um, so yeah, it's, it's, it, the browser will know it. And then of course you are, you know, welcome to, to proclaim it. Yeah. So, so, you know, just to recap, you know, brave, um, I've used it for a long time. Actually, at work, we are not allowed to use Brave, which makes me very sad.
小小的，一个小的 BAT 三角形，它会显示一个勾选标记，表示，哦，你是一个经过验证的创作者。所以这是 Brave 体验的一小部分。当然，那些想自豪地表明他们热爱 Brave 的创作者，我想，我想我们的，实际上我们的网站，如果你去 brave.com，那里有一堆品牌素材，我想他们可以使用。所以，所以是的，它，浏览器会知道它。然后当然你可以，你知道，欢迎大声宣告它。是的，所以，你知道，总而言之，你知道，Brave，我用了很长时间。实际上在工作时，我们不被允许使用 Brave，这让我非常伤心。
But to be fair to them, we're not allowed to use almost anything. They're very strict on IT. Is it like the... I know some IT policies flag it because it's got like a tor component that you can get or whatever oh i wish it was that complicated i think it's literally uh you know here's a list of programs you can use and uh you know we actually i mean to be fair like most of us are logging into the data center and doing everything there and over there we have root access and we can do anything we want but but um oh but but yeah so i had to use firefox and uh uh and even the you know installing the ad blocker it doesn't totally work all the
但平心而论，我们几乎什么都不被允许使用。他们的 IT 政策非常严格。是不是像……我知道有些 IT 政策会把它标记出来，因为它有一个你可以获取的 Tor 组件之类的？哦，我希望事情有那么复杂。我觉得它字面上就是，你知道，这里有一个你可以使用的程序列表，而且，你知道，我们实际上——平心而论，我们大多数人都是登录到数据中心并在那里做所有事情，在那里我们拥有 root 权限，我们可以做任何我们想做的事。但是，但是，哦，但是，是的，所以我不得不使用 Firefox，而且，甚至安装广告拦截器也并不总是完全管用。
time and i feel like some of these ad blockers are kind of compromised uh in the sense that you know they have deals with certain advertisers they say oh this is like a good ad and so we're going to keep this one and so brave is the only thing I've used recently, which just works. Just you install it. You don't have to do any plugins or anything. It just wipes all the ads that you don't like right off the face of the earth, which is amazing. Definitely folks should check it out. Yeah. I mean, there's a bunch of features I didn't even know about. So I'm really excited about that. I'm going to turn on the sync later today and try that out. Try out those features. Definitely use Brave. We're huge fans. And let's dive into the company here. So you joined a few years ago. And so what is sort of the growth of the company? Like, where is Brave now? And what's been that trajectory like? Yeah, you know, so I think around when I joined, I forgot the numbers back then, but it was,
而且我觉得其中一些广告拦截器在某种程度上被妥协了，因为，你知道，他们与某些广告商达成协议，他们说，哦，这是一个好广告，所以我们要保留这个。所以 Brave 是我最近使用的唯一一款能正常工作的软件。你只要安装它。你不需要做任何插件或任何东西。它直接把所有你不喜欢的广告从地球表面抹去，这太棒了。大家绝对应该去看看。是的。我是说，这里面有一堆我甚至都不知道的功能。所以我对此真的很兴奋。我等会儿就要开启同步功能并试一试。体验一下那些功能。一定要用 Brave。我们是它的超级粉丝。让我们深入聊聊这家公司吧。所以你几年前加入了。那么这家公司的发展情况如何？比如，Brave 现在发展到什么地步了？这段发展轨迹是怎样的？是的，你知道，所以我想在我加入的时候，我忘了当时的数字了，但那是，
you know, well, I actually remember when I first started talking, you know, to the Brave team, you know, actually years before, you know, we'd had a lot of interaction, I think it was like, few few 100,000 users, then, you know, this is this was years ago. And, you know, and, but I, I immediately loved it started started using it, you know, and, you know, the old electron based version, but, you know, yeah, it's, it's, it's grown just tremendously, you know, in the meantime, like, you know, I think it was, it was in January, we had, you know, yeah, it's, it's, it's grown just tremendously, you know, in the meantime, like, you know, I think it was, I think it was in January, we had, you know, over, over 50 million monthly active users, you know, across, you know, all, all, all those different, you know, platforms and, you know, and it's just, it's just a, you know, enormous and
你知道，其实我甚至记得我刚开始和Brave团队交流的时候，那是好几年前，当时我们的互动很多，我想那时大概只有几十万用户吧，这都是好几年前的事了。而且，我立刻就喜欢上了它，开始使用它，你知道的，那是基于旧版Electron的版本，但它在这期间真的增长得太惊人了。我想是在一月份的时候，我们在所有不同的平台上，拥有了超过5000万的月活跃用户，这真的非常巨大。
yeah, you know, it's, it's, it's been such, such an interesting trajectory because yeah, when, so even when I joined, you know, there's, there's been like an incredible amount of growth since then. And, and, you know, actually this, the team had done a lot of, of, you know, we work on this rewards program and, and on, you know, some of the ads already. But, you know, I came in and kind of help, helped sort of launch and, you know, grow it. And, you know, what started as just, you know, like, okay, you know, a few thousand users who was, you know, for the, you know, who'd sign up, who were like really interested, you know, has grown into millions. And, you know, and, and now it's like, you hear about it in, you know, all sorts of different, different venues, you know, and now it's like you hear about it in, you know, all sorts of different venues, you know, and it's like, okay, like you open up real periodicals, like you look in Forbes and it's like, oh, they're talking about Brave.
是的，你知道的，这段发展轨迹太有趣了，因为自我加入以来，也经历了惊人的增长。实际上，团队之前已经做了很多关于这个奖励计划以及一些广告的工作。但我加入后，可以说是协助推动并促进了它的增长。最初可能只有几千个真正感兴趣并注册的用户，而现在已经增长到了数百万。而且现在你会在各种不同的渠道听到关于它的消息，比如你看《福布斯》这样的知名杂志，他们也在讨论Brave。
And, you know, it's like it's such a cool thing, you know, because I sort of, you know, I either got used to working at companies where you didn't really, they were sort of, you know, B2B things. You didn't really hear people, you know, mention much or, you know, sort of smaller things. And this is, you know, it doesn't, you know, it doesn't take too many more kind of like doublings of our user base to start to become, you know, a significant portion of browsing and, you know, really, you know, a juggernaut. So it's like, you know, so that's very exciting, you know, but, you know, what I'd also say is that it like, you know, you see Brendan, Brendan Eich, CEO, like engage with people on Twitter, like every day, you know, and he's, he's like very famous for it. And, you know, keeps, keeps like very close to, you know, all those users, right?
而且你知道，这真的很酷，因为我以前习惯了在那些B2B公司工作，人们不太会经常提及它们，或者公司规模较小。而现在，我们的用户基数只要再翻倍几次，就会成为浏览器市场的重要组成部分，真正成为一个行业巨头。所以这非常令人兴奋。不过，我也想说的是，你看像CEO Brendan Eich，他每天都在Twitter上与用户互动，他为此非常知名，并且与所有这些用户保持着非常紧密的联系。
Like when, when people don't like things and people complain about stuff where they think it should be different, you know, if, if the idea is good, you know, it doesn't, doesn't matter sort of who or where it came from, you know, Brendan brings it to us and it's like, yeah, this is, this is, this is what we should do. You know, this is, uh, like our user, you know, the people who are passionate about us and support us, like they're, they're out there and about us and support us, they're out there and they're complaining about this. This drives them nuts or they wish we were working on this. What's the order of magnitude?
当人们不喜欢某些东西、抱怨某些事情或者认为应该有所改进时，如果这个想法不错，无论它来自谁或哪里，Brendan都会把它带给我们，说：“是的，这就是我们应该做的。”你知道，那些充满热情并支持我们的用户就在那里抱怨这些。这让他们抓狂，或者他们希望我们能改进这个。这差了多少个数量级？
When Brendan comes to the companies, how many engineers are we talking about? Is it tens of engineers, hundreds, thousands of engineers? We're definitely not in the thousands. I don't have an updated count, but we're certainly over 100 or so right now. Wow, that's cool. Yeah, it's exciting. And now we're working and like, yeah, now we're, we're, we're working on some, you know, really interesting pieces. Cause probably as you saw, like, you know, Brave acquired a search engine, right.
当Brendan来到公司时，我们有多少工程师？是几十个工程师，几百个，还是几千个工程师？我们绝对没有几千个。我没有最新的统计数字，但现在肯定超过100人左右了。哇，太酷了。是的，这很令人兴奋。现在我们正在开发一些非常有趣的功能。正如你可能看到的，Brave收购了一个搜索引擎，对吧？
And, and, and an associated team. And yeah, like I said, I love Brave search, you know, it's, it's that, that team just constantly amazes me. And like the growth has been like incredible there, you know, we're putting out sort of, you know, like premium sort of products, right. Like you've, um, you know, you can already get the VPN and iOS and you can, um, you know, you can get this premium brave talk, this, this zoom competitor, that's like, um, you know, real easy to join and, and anonymous and private, you know, again, by design. You know, that's a really interesting project, too, because, you know, Talk, which is based on open source Jitsi, and we work
还有一个相关的团队。是的，就像我说的，我喜欢Brave Search，那个团队总是让我惊叹不已。那里的增长速度简直不可思议，我们正在推出一些优质的产品。比如你已经可以在iOS上使用VPN，你还可以获取这个高级的Brave Talk，这是一个Zoom的竞争对手，加入非常简单，而且根据设计就是匿名和隐私的。你知道，这也是一个非常有趣的项目，因为Talk是基于开源的Jitsi，我们正在合作...
with, you know, the team that runs that now, too. You know, again, like, both really private by design, like we don't keep, you know, metadata about your calls or anything, you know, like that. You use these like anonymous credentials essentially to join things. But I think what it is also showed is that like, and in a lot of what we do, like you don't have to sacrifice, you know, really cool functionality to get privacy. Like we want users to have both, you know, like cool functionality to get privacy. Like we want, we want users to have both, you know, like, like what we love about Brave Talk is, you know, it's like you can generate a link and then just join it in your browser. Like so many, you know, so many of these like, like, you know, video conferencing kind of providers, you know, they like, they take
与现在运营该团队的人一起合作。同样的，两者的设计都非常注重隐私，我们不会保留关于你的通话或其他任何此类元数据。你基本上是使用这些匿名凭证来加入的。但我认为这也表明，在我们的很多工作中，你并不需要为了隐私而牺牲非常酷的功能。我们希望用户两者兼得。比如我们非常喜欢Brave Talk的一点是，你可以生成一个链接，然后直接在浏览器中加入。太多的视频会议提供商，他们把...
the experience outside of the browser And like, we want to make it a really good experience in the browser, because like, that's what people are using day in and day out, like 10 hours a day, you know? Yeah, my biggest pet peeve is when these video conferences, I've seen several do it. So it's not any particular one at fault, is where they'll give you a deep link that will take you to a browser just so that they can then open the desktop app it's like they couldn't even use like a desktop protocol deep link you know it's just so frustrating yeah that's right and so we want to make it just like like we you know we when we do engineering interviews like we we we do that too um you know we just we give them a talk link to
体验带到了浏览器外面，而我们希望在浏览器中提供真正好的体验，因为这正是人们日复一日、每天使用10个小时的东西。是的，我最讨厌的事情之一就是这些视频会议，我见过好几个都是这样，所以并不是哪一个特定软件的问题，它们会给你一个深层链接，把你带到一个浏览器，然后只是为了打开桌面应用。就好像它们甚至不能使用桌面协议的深层链接一样，这太让人沮丧了。是的，确实如此，所以我们希望让它变得简单。当我们进行工程面试时，我们也会这样做...
join and it's like and it's easy and they are able to show up. Like my nightmare always is like, oh, you're supposed to join this meeting. And like, oh, okay, there's a five-minute BlueJeans install that has to happen before you can do anything. You wake up at 5 a.m. with a cold sweat. It's like, what was that nightmare? Oh, it was I have had to use blue jeans again. Yeah. VC is, is the bane of, of so many, uh, people's existence. I mean, everyone really complains about VC. I haven't tried, uh, tried brave talk yet. I'm going to, I'm going to give it a shot. Um, what about like, uh, in terms of positions,
发给他们一个Talk链接让他们加入，这很简单，他们能够出席。我的噩梦总是，哦，你得加入这个会议，然后，哦，好吧，在你做任何事之前必须进行一个为期五分钟的BlueJeans安装。你会在半夜惊醒出冷汗，心想：那是什么噩梦？哦，原来我又得用BlueJeans了。视频会议真的是许多人生活的克星。我的意思是，每个人都在抱怨视频会议。我还没试过Brave Talk，我打算试试。那么，关于职位方面呢？
you have a lot of folks who are, you know, starting college, finishing college. And so they're looking for everything from, you know, internships over the summer all the way to, you know, full time positions. And we have people all over the world. So, you know, what are sort of the opportunities and what are the sort of locales there? Yeah, I'm like very glad you asked. So I definitely encourage everybody to head to the careers page, brave.com slash careers, because we're definitely hiring specifically for my team. Like we have four or five roles for my team. And I'm, you know, one of many teams here that, you know, has open roles. You know, we're always looking for great people to help us,
你们有很多刚刚开始上大学或即将毕业的人，所以他们正在寻找从暑期实习到全职工作的所有机会。我们在世界各地都有人，所以都有哪些机会和工作地点呢？很高兴你问起这个。我绝对鼓励每个人都去看看招聘页面 brave.com/slash/careers，因为我们确实在招人，尤其是我的团队。我的团队有四五个空缺职位，而且我是这里众多有空缺职位的团队之一。我们一直在寻找优秀的人才来帮助我们...
you know, run and scale these systems. And, you know, work-wise, we're actually, you know, we're very much remote first, you know, even pre-pandemic, you know. So, you know, there's an office in San Francisco, there's an office in Grand Cayman. Wait, there's an office in San Francisco, there's an office in Grand Cayman. Um, and, uh, there's an office in Grand Cayman. Like I think there's like eight or nine people there now. I mean, it's like, you know, and they even, you know, like, like, you know, hiring a lot of people locally and like, um, you know, people really like the life out there and we got it we have to double click on this so so how did that get started was this somebody who uh had a bunch of bitcoin so when i think of grand cayman i think of people trying to escape things i don't know i don't know if maybe i've watched too many movies
运营和扩展这些系统。在工作方式上，我们实际上非常推崇远程办公，甚至在疫情之前就是这样。所以，我们在旧金山有一个办公室，在大开曼岛有一个办公室。等等，我们在旧金山有一个办公室，在大开曼岛有一个办公室。嗯，在大开曼岛有一个办公室，我想现在那里大概有八九个人。我的意思是，你知道，他们甚至在当地招募了很多人，人们真的很喜欢那里的生活。我们得深入聊聊这个，那是怎么开始的？是不是有人有一堆比特币？因为当我想到大开曼岛时，我想到的是人们试图逃避某些事情，我不知道，也许我看太多电影了。
but is this like bitcoin millionaires and grand cayman or something i i i'm probably i can't tell you the gen i don't know the genesis of it but but I've known that since I've joined, you know, it was there and it's real, you know, right. It's like, yeah, people, people, you know, really love it. They really go out there and, and, you know. Like in the background, there's palm trees and everything. I bet it makes you jealous if you're in a meeting with them. It's gorgeous. And a lot of, you know, no, yeah. And no, it's like a wonderful office. And, you know, like a lot of awesome people out there. And so that is amazing. Yeah. And so, you know, San Francisco to, you know, and, and, but but for instance, a lot of us work remotely, right? I'm, I'm right outside of Orlando and have been, and then, you know, we usually, we'll usually get together for, you know, certainly pre-pandemic, we would do these, these like all hands and now, now again,
但这就像大开曼岛的比特币百万金吗？我可能说不上来，我不知道它的起源，但自我加入以来我就知道它一直都在，而且它是真实的。是的，人们真的很喜欢它。他们真的去那里……就像背景里有棕榈树和一切。我打赌如果你在开会时看到他们，你会嫉妒的。那里太美了。而且没有……是的，这是一个很棒的办公室，那里有很多超级棒的人。所以这太棒了。是的，从旧金山到……而且，但例如，我们很多人都远程工作。我住在奥兰多外面，一直都是这样。然后，我们通常会聚在一起，当然在疫情之前，我们会举办全体员工大会，现在很快...
very soon, you know, hopefully, and, you know, or, or we just, you know, fly out to see each other. Like when we were actually doing a lot of this work on sync, we were, you know, we actually flew out to like Arizona, because there were a couple of the engineers there. And we just like, we had a few days and, you know, and around Phoenix, right, and just had had a good time. So cool. No, it's, it's great. Like, you know we we hire all over the world i that's definitely the case for you know everybody uh you know on my team we span a number of time zones um and i think we've gotten you know pretty used to to working remotely and you know we're reasonably reasonably good at it i think cool that's awesome yeah very nice so
希望很快又能这样了，或者我们只是飞去见彼此。当我们实际做很多关于同步（sync）的工作时，我们实际上飞去了亚利桑那州，因为那里有几个工程师。我们在凤凰城附近待了几天，玩得很开心。太酷了。不，这真的很棒。我们世界各地都在招人，我的团队绝对也是这样，我们跨越了好几个时区。我认为我们已经对远程工作相当习惯了，而且我们在这方面做得相当不错。太酷了，太棒了，非常不错，所以...
so folks check out cruise oh Oh, about internships. Do you do internships? Or is it full time only? Yeah, we definitely have internships open. And I think this is like right about the time for it. And so I think we're, you know, we've, we're close to to bringing on some some interns here. So so you know, definitely if you know, send send your information my way if you're if you're interested. Cool. And what sort of skills are you looking for? Yeah, I mean, and, and, and there's, there's tons of different positions, you know, across, you know, there's like BD and design and engineering and, but, you know, look, definitely like Brave always, you know, I think is looking for people who are like,
大家去看看招聘页面吧。哦，关于实习。你们招实习生吗？还是只招全职？是的，我们确实开放了实习岗位。我想现在正是时候，所以我们差不多要迎来一些实习生了。因此，如果你感兴趣，一定要把你的简历发给我。太酷了。你们在寻找什么样的技能？是的，我的意思是，在各个部门有大量的不同职位，比如商务拓展、设计、工程等等。但是，绝对的，Brave一直在寻找那些...
one well versed in the browser, right? It's like this whole, you know, ecosystem, you know, unto itself. And, you know, I, and, and definitely for our team, you know, people who are, you know, great at, you know, scaling all this infrastructure, and, you know, keeping it reliable and cost effective, and all that other good stuff, because all these services are growing up and scaling and we want to make sure that we're still providing great service to our users. So if you're great at that, we're definitely always hiring for that. Let's see, what else? I know, some, some great data engineers. So if you, you do that, like, like, please, you know, please hit me up, you know, on Twitter.
首先，对浏览器非常熟悉的人。这是一个自成一体的生态系统。而且，对于我们的团队来说，绝对需要那些擅长扩展所有这些基础设施、保持其可靠性和成本效益以及所有这些好服务的人。因为所有这些服务都在成长和扩展，我们希望确保我们继续为用户提供优质的服务。如果你擅长这个，我们绝对一直在招聘。让我想想，还有什么？我知道，还有一些很棒的数据工程师。如果你做这个，请在Twitter上联系我。
But yeah, but look, great, great engineers, you know, great engineers overall who care about, you know, care about privacy and care about making the, you know, the best possible web, you know, we're happy to talk to you. Yeah, that makes sense. You know, this is actually a really good point. I think if you're out there and you've built something, a website or even something that has some kind of server component, take a little bit of time and get it to run on AWS. I'm kind of frugal to a fault and I didn't use public cloud stuff for a really long time because I didn't want to pay the 16 cents a month or whatever it was. That was not good. So don't do that. Basically, learn public cloud, get your stuff on AWS. For one, if you lose your hard drive, it's not a big
但是，是的，寻找优秀的工程师，真正关心隐私、关心创造出尽可能最好的网络环境的优秀工程师，我们都很乐意与你交流。是的，这很有道理。这其实是一个很好的观点。我想如果你在外面构建了某些东西，一个网站，甚至是一个带有某种服务器组件的东西，花点时间让它在AWS上运行。我有点过于节俭了，很长一段时间里我都没有使用公共云服务，因为我不想每月支付16美分或类似的费用。那可不好，所以别那样做。基本上，学习公共云，把你的东西放到AWS上。首先，如果你丢了硬盘，那就不是什么大问题了。
deal then. You still have your site. Number two, you're not going to tax your own personal computer and your own personal internet. I'd have issues where my home internet would go down for a day and I'd get people emailing me, Mame Hub is down and all these other things are down. And it's like, ah. But most importantly, you're going to build skills that are extremely, extremely important. I mean, the know, the, the public cloud services, um, and, and, and all of them are kind of learning from each other. So, so, so they, there's a whole ecosystem there that you could take some time to learn and, uh, and, and build some skills that are really, really in demand right now. Yeah, absolutely. Like we, we, um, we, we use AWS for a lot of different things.
你仍然有你的网站。第二，你不会给自己的个人电脑和个人网络带来负担。我曾经遇到过家里的网络断了一天，然后人们给我发邮件说 Meme Hub 崩溃了，其他所有东西都崩溃了，当时我就觉得，啊。但最重要的是，你将建立起极其重要的技能。我的意思是，公共云服务以及它们所有人都在互相学习，所以那里有一个完整的生态系统，你可以花时间去学习，并建立一些现在需求量非常大的技能。是的，绝对的。我们会在很多不同的事情上使用AWS。
Um, uh, you know, and look as, as, as an engineer, like I'm just a huge S3 fan, you know, We use AWS for a lot of different things. And look, as an engineer, I'm just a huge S3 fan. Diehard S3 fan. It is so useful in so many different ways. Yeah, I don't think we've had an episode on cloud file systems. We need to have you back, Jimmy, to talk about that. I'm sure there's people plenty more expertise there but okay cool hey it was um amazing to have you on the show i think um you know brave is an amazing browser i've used it for years it has never let me down um i've i've
你知道的，作为一个工程师，我只是AWS S3的超级粉丝。我们在很多不同的事情上使用AWS。作为一个工程师，我只是AWS S3的超级粉丝。S3的死忠粉。它在很多不同的方面都非常有用。是的，我想我们还没有做过关于云文件系统的节目。吉米，我们需要请你回来谈谈这个。我相信那里有更多专业知识的人，不过没关系。嘿，很高兴你能来到节目中。我觉得Brave是一个很棒的浏览器，我已经用了好几年了，它从未让我失望。我已经...
been a diehard fan um i don't know when brave started actually just really quick when did the when did the Brave project start in the sense that it was launched to the public? Oh, let's see. That's a good question. I should better know my Brave history. I've been using it for at least a few years now. We made it tool of the show maybe three, four years ago. And ever since then, I'm using it right now to record this. So it's an amazing piece of technology. Highly recommend it. And ever since then, I'm using it right now to record this. So it's an amazing piece of technology. Highly recommend it. And if you're producing content on the web, check out this whole bat system, be a creator on Brave. And if you are looking for some cool stuff to do this
成为了它的死忠粉。我不知道Brave是什么时候开始的，顺便问一下，Brave项目是什么时候以向公众发布的形式开始的？哦，让我想想。这是一个好问题。我应该更了解Brave的历史的。我至少已经使用它好几年了。我们可能在三四年前把它选为节目的明星工具。从那以后，我现在一直在用它来录音。所以这是一项了不起的技术，强烈推荐。如果你在网络上创作内容，看看这个整个BAT系统，成为Brave上的创作者。如果你正在寻找一些很酷的事情来做...
summer, check out the summer internships. There's also full-time positions, you know, a ton of a whole breadth of opportunity here. Awesome. Well, thanks for having me. This is great. Yeah. Thank you for coming on the show. We'll catch y'all later. music by eric barno programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute transmit the work to remix adapt the work but you must provide an attribution to Patrick and I and share a liking time. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
今年夏天，去看看暑期实习吧。这里还有全职岗位，你知道的，有大量的各种机会。太棒了，谢谢邀请我来，这太棒了。是的，谢谢你来参加节目。我们回头再聊。音乐由 Eric Barno 提供。Programming Throwdown 在知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 协议下发布。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输作品，进行混音和改编，但你必须注明我和帕特里克的署名，并采用相同的协议共享。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子即可发表评论。